bien bonjour à toutes et à tous la
commission d'enquête chargée d'établir
les raisons de la perte de souveraineté
et d'indépendance énergiques de la
France à l'honneur aujourd'hui de
recevoir Monsieur Lionel Jospin monsieur
le Premier ministre nous vous remercions
sincèrement d'avoir accepté de venir
exposer les principaux éléments de la
politique énergétique que vous avez mené
entre 1997 et 2002 à l'époque où vous
étiez Premier ministre période qui fut
caractérisée sur le plan politique par
une troisième cohabitation sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
Jacques Chirac et par une coalition
gouvernementale celle-ci s'est
manifestée notamment par la présence
dans votre gouvernement de ministre
appartenant au parti les Verts
la commission d'enquête procédera
d'ailleurs prochainement à l'audition de
maniame Dominique Voynet qui a bien
voulu également
se présenter aux membres de la
commission avec ses analyses comme vous
l'avez souhaité cette audition ce
cantonra a des échanges sur la politique
énergétique conduite au cours de vos
fonctions de Premier ministre soit de
1997 à 2002 je demanderai donc aux
membres de la commission de bien vouloir
respecter cette période
il m'appartient de donner en guise de
propos introductifs quelques éléments de
contexte
au cours des précédentes auditions
organisées par notre commission
d'enquête ont été évoquées deux
événements importants la fermeture
définitive de super Phénix et le sommet
de Barcelone de 2002 en faveur de la
libéralisation des marchés de
l'électricité et du gaz d'autres
éléments de contexte peuvent également
être relevés ainsi lors de la
déclaration du gouvernement sur la
politique énergétique organisée le 20
janvier 1997 à l'Assemblée nationale
Monsieur Christian Pierret secrétaire
d'État à l'industrie apposer le principe
du ni tout ni tout ni tout électrique ni
to gaz ou énergie fossile ni toute
énergie nouvelle et expérimentée la
volonté gouvernementale de mieux
associer le Parlement au choix
énergétique tout en dessinant une
nouvelle perspective Visante à confier à
une autorité indépendante la question de
la sûreté nucléaire
le protocole de Kyoto avait été signé en
1997 l'Allemagne s'ache cheminait vers
la sortie du nucléaire scellé par un
accord entre le gouvernement et les
électriciens sur la fermeture
progressive des centrales en juin 2000
on verra que l'histoire aura peut-être
fait un peu traîner cette date
au 1er janvier 1999 74 % du parc
français avait entre 11 et 20 ans 6%
entre 21 et 22 ans et 20% moins de 10
ans au cours de vos fonctions diverses
études composants comportant des
scénarios ont été produites et
maintenant notamment du Commissariat
général aux plans la commission énergie
2010-2020 avec exploré les jeux cite
chemin d'une croissance sobre et les
défis du long terme mais ce sont les
travaux que vous avez confiés à René
Pella au commissaire à l'énergie
atomique en mai 1999 qui sont
susceptibles de retenir plus
particulièrement l'attention de notre
commission avec le rapport dit Charpin
des supela il s'agissait d'une étude
économique prospective de la filière
nucléaire y compris le retraitement qui
abordait la question de la durée de vie
des centrale à l'horizon 2050 à cette à
cet horizon le scénario eau tablette sur
une consommation de 720 TW alors que le
scénario bat misait sur une consommation
de 535 TW la capacité nucléaire en 2050
étant estimée selon les scénarios entre
33 et 85 GB à comparer au 63 gigawatts
disponible en 2000
le rapport étudiait en effet à la fois
les technologies de maîtrise de la
demande d'électricité et les
technologies de production électrique de
l'amont à l'aval du cycle pour ceux qui
se concerne la filière nucléaire votre
audition monsieur le Premier ministre
devrait ainsi nous éclairer sur les
moyens dont disposer alors le
gouvernement pour définir une stratégie
énergétique je crois par ailleurs utile
de rappeler que François Roussely auquel
nous souhaitons une nouvelle fois rendre
hommage dirigeait EDF au cours de cette
période avant de vous donner la parole
monsieur le Premier ministre il me
revient de vous demander en application
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires de vous
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité et
rien que la vérité je vous invite donc à
lever la main droite et dire je le jure
merci beaucoup monsieur le Premier
ministre je vous laisse donc la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés
sachez que j'ai plaisir à me retrouver
devant une instance parlementaire même
si l'exercice qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui est particulier
j'ai en effet vécu des années
passionnantes à l'Assemblée nationale
d'abord comme député puis au banc du
gouvernement pendant deux décennies de
1980 à 2002 il y a deux décennies
n'étant pas doté d'hypermnésie la
préparation de votre audition m'a
conduit à redécouvrir le passé ce qui
n'a pas été déplaisant Emma obligé à
beaucoup travailler ce qui à mon âge et
peut-être salutaire le voyez dans cette
dernière phrase aucune allusion au
dossier des retraites sur lequel
naturellement je ne m'exprime pas
avant de vous retrouver j'ai eu des
échanges avec plusieurs de mes anciens
conseillères et conseillers à Matignon
et avec celui qui fut mon ministre de
l'Industrie pendant 5 ans Christian
Piret que vous avez cité je me suis même
rendu à Pierrefitte aux Archives
nationales pour consulter mes fonds qui
y sont déposés
j'ai fait mien le sujet de votre enquête
établi les raisons de la perte de
souveraineté et d'indépendance de la
France
quant à l'exposé introductif qui m'a été
demandé vous accepterez vous y avez fait
allusion monsieur le Président qu'il
soit centré sur la période pendant
laquelle j'ai gouverné 297 à 2002
à cette date j'ai quitté la vie
politique et mon expression publique est
devenue rare et mesurée à l'occasion de
cette audition je ne souhaite pas me
départir de l'attitude réservée qui est
désormais la mienne en conséquence pour
ne pas me laisser entraîner sur le
terrain de contreverse je ne
m'exprimerai pas sur les politiques de
l'énergie suivie par mes successeurs des
politiques dont je ne suis pas comptable
il en ira bien sûr différemment pour le
temps où j'ai gouverné comme ancien
Premier ministre j'ai à répondre de la
politique énergétique qui a été alors
poursuivi
comme nous étions en cohabitation nous
avons respecté les prérogatives du
président de la République Jacques
Chirac en particulier dans le champ de
la politique étrangère et européenne
pour autant dans cette période
l'article 20 de la Constitution
s'appliquait pleinement et mon
gouvernement a effectivement déterminé
et conduit la politique de la nation
il le faisait d'ailleurs dans une
relation étroite avec le Parlement en
particulier avec l'Assemblée nationale
où il a toujours disposé d'une majorité
avec laquelle il dialogue tout en
respectant l'opposition
étant responsable de la politique alors
menée je répondrai à votre
questionnement avec le souci de la
transparence et dans le respect du
sirmant que j'ai prêté il y a quelques
instants
je garderai à l'esprit bien sûr
l'interrogation centrale qui est la
vôtre et qui a trait à la souveraineté
et à l'indépendance énergétique de la
France
j'en viens au fond
la maîtrise de l'énergie et depuis la
révolution industrielle cruciale pour la
vie des nations
on le voit aujourd'hui dans le cas
extrême de la guerre quand l'agresseur
russe cherche à écraser le système
électrique de l'Ukraine
mais c'est vrai aussi en temps de paix
puisqu'il s'agit comme nous l'avons
voulu de fournir à notre économie une
énergie compétitive et à nos concitoyens
une énergie abordable
aujourd'hui
selon les chiffres de 2020 la
consommation française d'énergie
primaire est à environ 40% en énergie
nucléaire à 47% en énergie fossile
charbon pétrole gaz naturel et à 13% en
énergie renouvelable
alors la France ne dispose plus dans son
sous-sol des énergies fossiles et de
l'uranium lui permettant d'être
strictement indépendante
elle doit construire ça souveraineté ça
sécurité énergétique pour partie par des
alliances économiques et militaires et
aussi par des accords bilatéraux avec
des pays producteurs d'énergie primaire
la création de votre commission vient
ainsi à point nommer pour rappeler
l'importance de ces données et de ses
problématiques à nos concitoyens
je structurer mon propos autour des
trois sources d'énergie évoquées plus
haut je traiterai du nucléaire en
premier et le plus longuement non
seulement parce qu'il semble au centre
de vos préoccupations mais aussi parce
qu'il est le secteur ou l'État
stratège régulateur et actionnaires
industriel ou les responsabilités oui
sont majeures
je parlerai ensuite des énergies
fossiles dont nous restons dépendants
j'évoquerai enfin les énergies
renouvelables dont nous espérons
davantage
dans ces trois champs mon gouvernement
agit avec sérieux et à chercher à se
montrer prévoyant il a été guidé aussi
par la préoccupation d'apporter à nos
concitoyens une énergie fiable et
abordable pour tous c'est pourquoi avec
le recul du temps je pense pouvoir dire
en réponse aux interrogations légitimes
qui sont les vôtres que la politique
conduite entre
1997 et 2002 n'a pas entraîné une perte
de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique pour la France
dans le domaine du nucléaire la
politique de mon gouvernement c'est
naturellement inscrite dans un continuum
historique quand le monde est entré dans
l'air atomique en 1945
c'est une volonté d'indépendance qui a
conduit le général de Gaulle et la
Quatrième République a lancé un
programme nucléaire
la France c'est dotée d'une arme de
dissuasion et d'une filière
d'enrichissement de l'uranium
d'utilisation civile notamment pour
produire de l'électricité
le premier choc pétrolier en 1973 sous
le gouvernement de Pierre Metz Lemaire
puis la présidente de Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing a provoqué une puissante
accélération du programme nucléaire
civil visant à rendre la production
d'électricité moins dépendante des
approvisionnements pétroliers du
Proche-Orient
cette politique a été poursuivie un
rythme plus modéré en raison de
l'évolution des besoins sous les
présidents de François Mitterrand
en 30 ans de 1971 à 2002 la France s'est
équipée de 58 réacteurs nucléaires les
derniers ont été mis en service entre
1997 et 2002
quand nous arrivons au responsabilités
en 1997 le parc nucléaire fournit plus
de 75% de l'électricité française
cette situation semble excellente pour
l'indépendance du pays mais elle se
heurte à deux difficultés la première
est technique les centrales nucléaires
sont adaptées aux consommations dites de
base constante par exemple pour fournir
des usines mais elles sont moins
adaptées pour les consommations de
pointe par exemple un pic de
consommation par grand froid pour
lesquels il est préférable de produire
de l'électricité avec de l'hydraulique
ou du gaz
l'autre difficulté touche à la sécurité
des approvisionnements
idéalement il est souhaitable de
répartir les risques entre plusieurs
énergies primaires la trop grande
dépendance à une seule source peut-être
problématique on l'a vu encore tout
récemment en 2022 avec l'excessive
dépendance de l'Allemagne au gaz russe
ou dans une moindre mesure avec les
défaillances de soudure détectées dans
certaines centrales françaises mettant
plusieurs tranches à l'arrêt et faisant
craindre des coupures d'électricité dans
l'hiver 2023 qui heureusement semble ne
pas devoir se produire en outre deux
changements de nature très différentes
vont venir perturber le système
énergétique français dans les années 80
et 90
le premier et le choc provoqué dans les
opinions publiques par les accidents
nucléaires de freemile Island en 1979
aux États-Unis et à Tchernobyl dans
l'Ukraine soviétique en 1986 une
méfiance à l'égard du nucléaire s'est
exprimée dans une partie de la
population en France et avec plus de
force encore dans d'autres démocraties
européennes cela a contribué à la montée
en puissance du courant de l'écologie
politique ce sera l'une des raisons de
la décision allemande
ultérieure d'arrêter le nucléaire après
l'accident de Fukushima en 2011
l'autre changement n'est d'une évolution
la construction européenne fondée sur la
libre circulation des biens et des
services entre pays européens
a remis en cause le modèle industriel
français de monopole qui dans l'énergie
avec conduit aux organisations de DF de
Framatome et du CEA
que unique européen
accepté par le président Mitterrand et
le chancelier call et entrer en vigueur
en 1987 à inclus les services publics à
la française dans le processus
d'intégration européenne
la négociation des directives qui sont
des suivis régulant le marché intérieur
de l'électricité qui ont démarré en 1990
ont abouti à un accord en
1996 sous la présidence de Jacques
Chirac
quel est le contexte quand les élections
législatives de 1997 porte une nouvelle
majorité aux responsabilités
pendant les 5 années de mon gouvernement
le nucléaire sera une composante
essentielle de la politique énergétique
du pays nos actions dans le champ du
nucléaire civil viseront donc à
renforcer la filière industrielle et à
lui redonner sa crédibilité dans
l'opinion je vais énumérer brièvement
maintenant ces actions
certes nous avons fermé super Phénix
à ceux qui ont dit que ce choix était
strictement politique je répondrai ceci
en annonçant cette intention dans
l'accord signé avec les vers nous avons
informé dument l'opinion avant les
législatives et les électeurs ont fait
leur choix car la politique c'est aussi
instaurer une relation de confiance avec
les citoyens par la transparence en
outre en démocratie
dirait-on que les choix énergétiques qui
engagent un pays sur des dizaines
d'années sont purement techniques et non
pas politique ce serait singulier
pour autant les raisons de la fermeture
de super Phénix ont été avant tout
industriels la technologie du
chirurgénérateur était séduisante
théoriquement le plutonium obtenu lors
de l'utilisation de l'uranium dans les
centrales classiques laisse cette
espérer un usage comme combustible pour
produire de l'électricité dans la
filière du surgénérateur en outre la
transmutation espérée des matières
nucléaires semblait ouvrir une voie à
l'élimination des déchets
mais la centrale dite sur générateur
lancé à Chris Malville en 1977 est
terminée en 1987 était un échec
industriel elle n'avait jamais
fonctionné de façon stable elle avait
subi ainsi dans sur incident et connu de
longs arrêts de fonctionnement les
technologies employées étaient risquées
puisque le sodium explose au contact de
l'eau et elle n'était pas maîtrisée
après 20 ans d'effort
le projet qui devenait lourd
financièrement pour EDF ne promettait
pas le succès par contre les recherches
sur la transmutation des déchets
nucléaires ont été poursuivis par la
relance du réacteur Phoenix
en outre la fermeture de super Phénix ne
fragilise pas la sécurité énergétique du
pays
notons en effet que le projet Astrid de
réacteur à neutrons rapides repris par
le CEA en 2010 a été à son tour arrêté
25 ans après notre décision cette
technologie n'a prospérer dans aucun
pays
occidental notamment pas aux États-Unis
au Japon qu'il avait exploré même si
elle semble avoir s'il semble-t-il elle
a débouché en Russie et peut-être en
Chine dans des conditions que nous ne
connaissons guère
ainsi solder l'échec industriel était
une décision rationnelle et raisonnable
qui ne portait atteinte ni à la
dépendance ni à la souveraineté
énergétique du pays
après cette décision que j'assume
pleinement nous avons engagé de
nombreuses actions pour sécuriser la
filière nucléaire française et assurer
la crédibilité de l'État dans ses
responsabilités de contrôle
nous avons renforcé la filière MOX qui
permet de mélanger des oxydes de
plutonium et d'uranium pour réduire la
quantité de plutonium dit sur étagère
elle est une compétence française de
pointe dans le monde et elle permet de
réduire notre dépendance aux
importations d'uranium dans la période
1997 cette technologie a été introduite
dans 10 tranches nucléaires
supplémentaires
nous avons préparé la valse du cycle on
le sait l'une des critiques principales
adressées au nucléaire et l'accumulation
de déchets radioactifs en décidant la
création du laboratoire de bure dans des
terrains argileux étangs nous avons
permis d'étudier dans le détail la
possibilité de stocker de manière
réversible les déchets à haute activité
et à vie longue en limitant au maximum
le risque d'exposition pour les
générations futures
nous sommes sans doute devenus le pays
nucléaire le plus avancé au monde sur la
question de la valve du cycle
nous avons intégré sur T nucléaire et
radioprotection
en France la Sûreté Nucléaire
c'est-à-dire la maîtrise des risques
industriels étaient assurée par des
organisations solides à la compétence
reconnue en revanche la radioprotection
c'est-à-dire la maîtrise des risques
pour la santé des populations étaient
sous équipés elle répondait maléisément
aux inquiétudes de l'opinion on l'avait
constaté au moment de l'accident de
Tchernobyl
mon gouvernement a donc décidé de
rapprocher la sûreté nucléaire et la
radioprotection en réunissant les deux
missions
par la création en février 2002 de la
direction générale de la sûreté
nucléaire et de la radioprotection la
radioprotection et l'attention portée au
risque pour la santé ont été renforcés
nous avons ainsi redonner de la
crédibilité aux autorités publiques de
contrôle et plus largement à la parole
de l'État
d'autant que parallèlement nous avons
lancé la création d'une autorité de
contrôle indépendante c'était
indispensable car dans l'opinion se
répandait l'idée que les organismes de
contrôle placé sous l'autorité des
gouvernements pouvaient être soumis à
leur influence et ne pas être
suffisamment crédible pour des raisons
administratives diverses cette autorité
indépendante l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a finalement été créé par une
loi le 13 juin 2006 donc après la fin de
mon gouvernement mais c'était le
prolongement de notre initiative et
cette loi a été votée de manière
consensuelle au Parlement à l'Assemblée
comme au cinéma
nous avons préparé la nouvelle
génération des centrales nucléaires dans
la période 1986 17 2002 la France
arrivait à la fin d'un cycle de 30 ans
de construction nucléaire de centrale
nucléaire nous avons en effet mis en
service commercial de nouvelles
centrales celle de chaux et de Civaux
et nous avons poursuivi les études
nécessaires pour préparer la génération
future de centrale nucléaire les EPR
destinés à compléter ou remplacer les
premières centrales nucléaires mises en
production à la fin des années 1970
nous avons renforcé les acteurs du
nucléaire comme COGEMA et framatone en
réorganisant leur axonia leur action n'a
rien
la filière française d'enrichissement et
de retraitement était un leader mondial
qui exportait son savoir-faire dans
plusieurs pays notamment en Allemagne et
en Japon elle a été un moment fragilisé
par le refus du gouvernement allemand de
reprendre les déchets de son industrie
nucléaire retraitée à la Hague après une
négociation difficile avec le
gouvernement fédéral dans laquelle je
suis personnellement intervenu et je
peux vous le dire avec force auprès de
Gerard Schroeder le chancelier allemand
nous avons obtenu la reprise des
transports de déchets de la France vers
l'Allemagne ce qui resterait des marges
pour l'entreposage des déchets et à
redonner de la visibilité aux
industriels
nous avons également stabilisé
l'actionnariat de Framatome après le
retrait de plusieurs industriels dans
ces minces en l'adossant à COGEMA créant
ainsi un industriel public dont la
taille était adaptée aux investissements
à venir même si c'est la structure
ensuite a beaucoup bougé nous avons
correctement intégré le système
électrique français dans son
environnement européen conformément aux
engagements pris par deux présidents
François Mitterrand avec l'Acte unique
et Jacques Chirac avec l'adoption de
l'active directive européenne de 1996
ainsi le Parlement a-t-il adopté la loi
de régulation de l'électricité du 10
février 2010 loi Pierret ouvrant la fin
de façon limitée le marché français à la
concurrence européenne nous l'avons fait
en renforçant le service public de
l'électricité sans fragiliser la filière
nucléaire nous avons maintenu le
monopole dit naturel du réseau
électrique au sein d'EDF sous le
contrôle du autorité indépendante de
régulation et nous avons ouvert la
concurrence européenne
à la concurrence européenne pardon la
fourniture d'électricité au gros
consommateurs industriels et AE seule en
outre cette loi a mis en place le
financement du service public
d'électricité permettant à tous
d'accéder à cette énergie à un coût
abordable ce dispositif bien calibré
pour la filière française a d'ailleurs
permis à EDF d'accroître ses positions
en Europe et dans le monde en tirant
partie de son avantage compétitif
nucléaire
quant aux décisions de régulation
critique et aujourd'hui aucune et
notamment par l'obligation faite à EDF
de revendre l'électricité nucléaire a
pris coûtant à ses concurrents de dates
de mon gouvernement ni ne peut trouver
sa cause dans des décisions prises par
lui
j'espère donc vous avoir montrer que
pendant 5 ans nous avons agi avec esprit
de responsabilité prévoyance pour
préserver la filière nucléaire et son
avenir sans affaiblir la souveraineté et
l'indépendance énergétique de notre pays
maintenant plus brièvement les énergies
fossiles charbon pétrole gaz naturel et
la façon dont mon gouvernement les a
appréhendés
naturellement la réalité du
réchauffement climatique était connue
alors même si le rythme d'accélération
du phénomène et la perception collective
de ces dangers et témoins aigus
toutefois les énergies fossiles
représentaient encore à l'époque plus de
50% de la consommation totale de la
France avec des secteurs comme
l'extransport ou aucune solution
alternative n'existait à l'époque notre
politique a donc consisté à marier la
préparation de la transition énergétique
vers des énergies non carbonées et la
sécurisation de nos approvisionnements
en énergie fossile nous avons donc
réduit la consommation de charbon la
source la plus importante des missions
de carbone dans l'atmosphère nous avons
fermé les mines de Carmaux d'Alès et de
Gardanne tout en organisant le
réaménagement des sites et la formation
des enfants des mineurs à de nouveaux
métiers nous avons également fermé la
centrale à charbon de pinceau
nous avons en outre sécuriser et
diversifier nos approvisionnements
pétroliers et gaziers par des accords
avec des pays producteurs notamment au
Venezuela en Angola en Arabie saoudite
et en Iran en même dans ces deux
derniers pays un pourcentage garanti de
certaines de leurs réserves nous avons
travaillé à la création de nouvelles
routes d'enlèvement de pétrole
d'Azerbaïdjan afin d'en sécuriser
l'approvisionnement nous avons également
participé à des négociations
internationales avec les pays
producteurs afin de limiter la hausse
potentielle des prix du pétrole et ce à
des niveaux extrêmement bas il est vrai
que c'était dans un tout autre contexte
que celui d'aujourd'hui
dans ce secteur nous avons là encore
chercher à renforcer les acteurs
ainsi avons-nous accompagné la fusion
entre Total et Elf en 1999
alors que le duel fratricide des deux
entreprises créent le risque d'une prise
de contrôle par un industriel étranger
si total est aujourd'hui un acteur
essentiel de la sécurité de la
provisionnement pétrolier gazier
français mais aussi désormais une
entreprise engagée dans la transition
énergétique c'est bien parce que nous
avons
œuvré à la création de ce champion
national doté d'une grande capacité
d'investissement
ce rappel de la volonté qui a été la
nôtre de sécuriser nos
approvisionnements tout en préparant la
transition énergétique me conduit pour
finir à parler des énergies non carbones
cinq ans après la conférence de Rio en
1992 la deuxième grande conférence
internationale sur le changement
climatique a eu lieu en décembre 1997 à
Kyoto nos délégués ont été très actifs
dans la négociation et la ratification
du Protocole de Kyoto fut au repérer par
la loi du 10 juillet 2000
tirant les leçons de cette négociation
nous avons commencé à associer
étroitement les scientifiques à nos
équipes de diplomates rattrapant ainsi
un retard par rapport aux structures
mises en place chez nos grands
partenaires
nous avons amorcé la transformation de
l'action extérieure de la France en
matière de développement durable ces
idées seront reprises et mises en oeuvre
par nos successeurs la jonction et la
mobilisation de ces compétences seront
utiles plus tard lorsqu'il s'agira de
négocier l'accord de Paris
toujours à Kyoto la France a défendu le
principe d'une taxe carbone et le
soutien du financement de la transition
dans les pays en développement
si la taxe carbone n'a pas abouti à
cause des divergences inter-européennes
mon gouvernement a préparé dès après
Kyoto la mise en place du marché
européen des droits des missions qui est
aujourd'hui l'instrument principal de la
politique climat de l'Union européenne
nous l'avons fait en associant les
énergéticiens et les acteurs industriels
français à la préparation de ce marché
en 1997 nous avons renforcé la mission
inter ministérielle sur l'effet de serre
placé auprès du premier ministre cette
structure a joué un rôle majeur pour la
mise en cohérence des politiques menées
dans chaque département ministériel
elle a montré que la lutte contre le
changement climatique touchait tous les
secteurs agricultures transports où nous
avons privilégié l'orage le rail
bâtiment aménagement du territoire
économie numérique etc et qu'elle devait
concerner chacun en France
nous avons finalisé en 2000 le premier
programme national de lutte contre le
changement climatique destiné à réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sur la période 2000 2010 c'est l'ancêtre
du plan climat en 2000 encore un grand
plan d'énergie a été lancé pour répondre
à la hausse des prix du pétrole du
moment mais aussi dans un but de lutte
contre le réchauffement les moyens de
l'ADEME ont augmenté de plus de 50% dans
les cinq années de mon gouvernement
en outre sur une initiative
parlementaire le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale ont adopté à l'unanimité le 17
février 2001
la loi qui modifie le code de
l'environnement et qui dans son article
premier confère à la lutte contre
l'intensification de l'effet de serre et
à la prévention des risques liés au
réchauffement climatique le caractère de
priorité nationale nous avons ainsi créé
l'observatoire national sur les effets
du réchauffement climatique chargés de
collecter et de diffuser des
informations et de formuler des
recommandations à destination du
gouvernement et du Parlement
si j'ai déjà longuement parlé de la
première des énergies non carbonées le
nucléaire nous étions conscients dès
1997-2002 de l'arthante obligation de
faire évoluer notre système énergétique
national vers une complémentarité du
nucléaire et des airs et des énergies
renouvelables pour progressivement
remplacer les énergies fossiles
la première de ces énergies
renouvelables et bien sûr l'hydraulique
ici nous avons organisé la
transformation de la Compagnie nationale
du Rhône
en producteur d'électricité hydraulique
de plein exercice en partenariat avec un
autre énergéticien français Suez ce qui
a sécurisé et stabilisé le secteur de
l'hydraulique
la deuxième ressource est l'éolien il
était encore à l'époque au stade
embryonnaire nous avons adopté en 2001
décret volontaristes conduisant EDF à
acheter l'électricité éolienne un prix
sécurisé à l'avance 55 centimes d'euros
le kilowatt-heure pendant 5 ans puis une
rémunération décroissante sur 10 ans
en ce qui concerne l'énergie
photovoltaïque la loi du 10 février 2000
relatives à la modernisation et au
développement du service de
l'électricité à instaurer un mécanisme
d'obligation d'achat de la production
d'électricité photovoltaïque en vue
d'intéresser les particuliers et de
rentabiliser leur investissement plus
globalement c'est pendant la présidence
française et sous son impulsion que
l'Union européenne a adopté une
directive fixant pour la première fois
des objectifs chiffrés sur les EnR au
plan national la loi d'aménagement et de
développement durable du territoire de
1999 dites loi voinet à instaurer les
premiers exercices de prospective
énergétiques territoriale française il
est vrai qu'il ne survivront pas à
l'alternance
en conclusion j'espère que cette
introduction vous aura éclairé sur
l'état d'esprit qui nous a animé pendant
nos cinq années de responsabilité
gouvernementale elle vous aura aussi
rappelé les réalisations qui ont été les
nôtres aujourd'hui s'il m'ait permis de
nous projeter vers l'avenir je me
réjouis que la technologie prometteuse
de la fusion nucléaire dans le cadre du
large progrès International de Recherche
et d'ingénierie ITER et trouver en
France sa principale installation j'y
voilà reconnaissance de l'excellence
française que nous nous sommes efforcés
de servir
l'énergie est un secteur de l'activité
humaine qui s'inscrit dans la longue
durée
mais où surgit parfois l'impératif de
décision rapide
à ces deux échelles du temps l'une qui
implique la prévoyance l'autre qui
impose la réactivité mon gouvernement a
voulu servir le pays
œuvrer à la compétitivité de notre
économie améliorer le sort de nos
concitoyens et sauvegarder la
souveraineté et l'indépendance de la
France
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pour ce propos introductif
précis et pour les travaux de
préparatoires que celui-ci reflète
j'aurai une première question d'ordre
très général
finalement quelle est la place de la
question énergétique dans les
préoccupations dans l'ordre des
priorités en quelque sorte de votre de
votre gouvernement dans cette période
entre 1997 et 2002 histoire de nous
repositionner un peu dans le contexte
c'est une période qui a duré cinq ans et
dans laquelle le gouvernement que je
dirais la majorité qui m'a appuyé
constamment
ont agi sur des plans extrêmement
différents il est bien évident que la
façon dont nous sommes investis dans la
lutte le contrôle le chômage qui était
une priorité dans la confection de la
loi sur les 35 heures dans les
empoisonnent a été une dimension
extrêmement importante
dans d'autres domaines encore des
domaines sociaux des domaines sociétaux
nous avons agi mais en même temps pour
nous l'énergie était le soubassement sur
lequel pouvait s'appuyer l'industrie
française
et et nous avons donc considéré que
c'était un élément essentiel de notre
politique
j'ai eu la chance d'être entouré par des
conseillers
et conseillère qui est de très bonne
qualité dont les noms peuvent être
d'ailleurs maintenant connus contenu des
responsabilités qu'ils ont exercé et je
ne les citerai pas bien sûr et puis j'ai
eu un très bon ministre et il était
secrétaire d'État parce que je ne
voulais un gouvernement resserré donc il
ne pouvait pas y avoir plus de 15
ministres mais il avait véritablement
une fonction pleinement ministérielle
Christian Pierret dont je crois
d'ailleurs
que il serait tout à fait disposé à vos
venir devant votre commission car il est
plus technicien que moi
de ces sujets si vous souhaitiez
éventuellement pour tel ou tel point que
vous avez vu le rapport pela je suis pas
sûr que j'ai relu entièrement malgré le
temps que j'ai consacré à la préparation
de cette audition le rapport peut là
mais donc il est aussi à votre
disposition donc c'était pour nous
quelque chose d'essentiel et ça
d'ailleurs été peut-être une des raisons
d'un quiproquo sur la tonalité ou les
orientations de notre politique
énergétique après tout ça a commencé par
une première annonce qui était la
suppression de super Phénix
mais sur laquelle je suis évidemment
prêt à revenir en dehors de ce que j'ai
dit dans mon intervention donc oui le
à la confluence de la politique
nationale de la politique industrielle
que nous avons conduites et qui fait que
en 5 ans les emplois industriels en
France sont restés stables
c'est un chiffre important ou une donnée
importante que je veux rappeler c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas eu de décroissance
pendant cette période des emplois
industriels indépendamment des mesures
sociales que nous avons prises et je
pense que c'est en partie dû à la
capacité de
l'infrastructure
énergétique française que nous nous
sommes et forcés de servir donc aux
questions est très générale je sais pas
si je la cadre suffisamment mais comme
je vous l'ai dit ça a été pour nous un
point essentiel et d'ailleurs il y avait
plusieurs de mes ministres Christian
pierre est bien sûr Dominique Voynet
naturellement ils ont dialogué souvent
mais aussi Dominique Strauss-Kahn en
tant que mythologie et celui qui lui a
succédé Claude Allègre qui était un
physicien et qui s'occupait de la
recherche notamment donc c'est vraiment
il y avait des personnalités importantes
du gouvernement qui était extrêmement
attentive à ces sujets et qui ont
constamment dialogué le plus souvent
évidemment sous mon autorité et pour des
arbitrages pendant cette période
alors au début de votre gouvernement il
y a
protocole de Kyoto qui est qui est
adopté est-ce que ça marque un tournant
une bifurcation ou est-ce que c'est
plutôt une poursuite de d'enjeux autour
des gaz à effet de serre qui était déjà
perçus et seconde question dans la
question dans la question comment être à
l'époque perçue le nucléaire dans la
perspective de ce qu'on appelle alors il
me semble la lutte contre les gaz à
effet de serre on peut parler peut-être
moins de décarbonation comme on en parle
aujourd'hui
non je parlerai pas d'une rupture ce
serait peut-être
se vanter à l'excès il y avait déjà une
conférence de Rio on était dans un
processus de prise de conscience
simplement le fait de avoir une ministre
de l'Environnement important qui c'est
inscrite dans cette négociation dans
cette discussion à certainement
positionner la France d'une certaine
façon et comme je l'ai dit la capacité
que nous avons eu à progressivement
intégrer
à nos diplomates des équipes
scientifiques à changer aussi la vision
des choses si vous voulez et notamment
la diplomatie française dans le domaine
de l'environnement non sur ce terrain
aussi parce que la prise de conscience
elle était
moins aigu qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
inscrits dans un processus nous n'étions
pas encore où nous ne croyons pas encore
à l'époque être dans la phase de l'AC
qui est maintenant en train de se
produire sous nos yeux
et quand on est clair
[Musique]
c'était une énergie non carbonée les
problèmes du nucléaire sont bien
évidemment la production de déchets sont
aussi les problèmes de sécurité c'est
une énergie
qui n'est pas dangereuse tant qu'elle
est sûr mais qui peut-être
potentiellement dangereuse les accidents
l'ont démontré et donc
ce nucléaire pour nous
il jouait un rôle essentiel
de ce point de vue même si des enceintes
telles que celle de Kyoto étaient
peut-être pas seul ou
cet argument pouvait être développé avec
le plus de l'iris
parce qu'on retrouve des déclarations de
cette époque-là ou notamment votre
Ministre de l'Environnement de l'époque
Dominique Vanet
explique à quel point peut-être que le
charbon peut-être encore être une
énergie d'avenir pour se substituer au
nucléaire qui est dangereux c'est un peu
contradictoire finalement avec ce que
vous venez de dire sur la perception
déjà de du nucléaire comme une énergie
décarbonée et de l'enjeu de la
décarbonation
normalement
madame voisin aurait dû déjà répondre à
cette question avant que cette audition
n'est lieu
sur l'audition a été décalée je lui
laisserai peut-être le soin de répondre
sur ce point particulier
de toute façon les données de l'énergie
nucléaire restent les mêmes quant à la
réalité du charbon et de ses
dangers du point de vue du réchauffement
climatique elle est absolument avérée
aujourd'hui
dans votre propos introductif vous avez
présenté la décision de la fermeture de
super Phénix comme une décision d'ordre
industriel
si j'ai bien écouté les propos qui ont
été les vôtres
pourtant
les éléments semblent faire quand même
apparaître que super Phénix était un
enjeu de
d'accord politique puisque vous avez
aussi précisé que c'était dans votre
programme commun et d'arbitrage
interministériel avec des oppositions à
l'époque fortes notamment de votre
Ministre de l'Économie et de l'industrie
ou enfin Dominique Strauss-Kahn j'ai
plus qu'elle était la délégation exacte
qui semblait plutôt favorable au
maintien de super Phénix est-ce que
c'est vraiment une décision industrielle
ou c'est plutôt le volet programmatique
et équilibre de la la gauche plurielle
qui qui détermine ce choix
j'ai commencé à répondre sur ce point
mais je vais
précisément propos et en même temps
d'abord l'élargir je crois que c'est une
erreur profonde à propos du gouvernement
que j'ai conduit pendant cinq ans et
de l'influence qui aurait exécée les
Verts en particulier que de se focaliser
justement sur les verres je m'adresse
ici à des députés qui sont au fait des
réalités politiques donc je voudrais en
rappeler une essentielle et qui touche
justement à cette majorité plurielle que
vous avez évoqué
sur les cinq parties qui composent la
majorité plurielle qui se constitue en
1997 avec une série d'acteurs
bilatéraux mais qui se constitue
fondamentalement à partir de la victoire
aux élections législatives 4 sont
favorables au nucléaire le PS le PC les
radicaux de gauche et le MDC
ça c'est une première donnée si vous
regardez quelle est la réalité
parlementaire à l'époque
il y a à l'Assemblée nationale dans la
majorité
248 socialistes
35 communistes
PG partir radicaux j'ai pas entendu
on a le droit de rêver au passé et pour
préparer des rêves de l'avenir bon ne
m'emmenez pas sur le terrain de la
politique d'aujourd'hui donc 14
radicaux de gauche 9
MDC et huit verres c'est à dire que les
vers représentent à l'Assemblée
nationale 8 députés sur les 314 députés
qui composent ma majorité je peux vous
dire une chose
si la politique que nous avons conduit
et que j'ai essayé d'illustrer dans mon
intervention luminaire avait été en quoi
que ce soit négative pour le secteur
nucléaire français j'aurais eu des
problèmes à l'intérieur de cette
majorité qui a été constamment cohérente
sur les sujets de l'énergie donc
l'hiver non à mon sens pas peser
négativement je pourrais y revenir si
vous voulez qu'on parle de la ministre
pour lui adresser quelques compliments
inventions d'audition
les Verts n'ont en rien pesé
négativement dans le domaine du
nucléaire quel côté leur conviction et
ils ne se sont pas ralliés évidemment à
l'industrie nucléaire
mais ils ont joué un rôle important
sur la question de la sûreté
ils ont joué un rôle
utile même s'il a été impuret ambivalent
sur la question du contrôle de
l'indépendance des autorités de contrôle
parce que les verres hésitaient un peu
parce que ils se rendent compte que
un des effets d'une autorité de contrôle
indépendante était la légitimation de
ces observations et donc d'une certaine
façon de la filière et pendant un temps
peut-être aurait-il été tenté qu'on
reste avec la tutelle hiérarchique des
ministères à condition évidemment que
l'environnement inoccupe une place mais
ensuite ils ont joué y compris dans ce
domaine de du contrôle indépendant un
rôle utile ils ont aussi je pense
étaient utiles sur un autre point c'est
qu'ils ont contribué à aérer un secteur
ou des décisions de caractère
technocratique venue d'en haut était
quand même l'usage et en insistant sur
la dimension démocratique des décisions
prises du pour qu'elle soit ses
décisions pour qu'elles soient comprises
par l'opinion et puis enfin bien sûr
c'est les questions environnementales et
développement durable ils ont aussi
également été précieux donc
je voudrais
répondre à cette fable selon laquelle la
présence d'une ministre vert et d'un
secrétaire d'État au gouvernement et de
8 députés sur plus de 300 dans la
majorité aurait pesé sur la politique
énergétique de la France et en
particulier sur sa politique nucléaire
du coup on a on a retrouvé la trace d'un
conseil des ministres Romains
on a retrouvé du coup la trace d'un
conseil des ministres européens qui se
tient en 2000 à La Haye sur ces
questions d'énergie et dans lequel
finalement une position
défavorable au nucléaire notamment sur
le plan
prospectif
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on l'a vu c'est concrétisé
sur la bataille autour de la taxonomique
était très très compliquée pour pour la
France qui trouve ses origines en 2000 à
la haie ou c'est Dominique Vanet qui
représentait le gouvernement français
avec un mandat de votre part
des témoignages qu'elle a pu dire de
défendre le nucléaire
ce qu'elle a
ce qu'elle n'a pas fait en lien avec le
ministre anglais et dans votre dos en
quelque sorte c'est le témoignage
qu'elle a pu donner publiquement quel
était donc la nature du mandat que vous
aviez confié à Dominique voannet à
l'occasion de cette réunion des
ministres européens vous faites allusion
au mécanisme de développement propre
c'est ça
alors on m'a cité une vidéo
dans lequel la ministre s'exprime
et j'ai remarqué que cette vidéo avait
été filmée apparemment je n'en connais
pas le contexte si vous voulez je ne
mets pas en doute son authenticité mais
je constate qu'elle a été filmée après
2002 c'est-à-dire alors que Dominique
Venen n'était plus dans mon gouvernement
alors
il faut quand même savoir que ce
mécanisme
de développement propre et sur ce
mécanisme de développement propre la
France était de toute façon isolée dans
l'Union européenne et les pays membres
de l'Union européenne
n'était pas favorable à ce que le
nucléaire se voit intégrer disons dans
ce mécanisme comme une énergie jugée
propre donc je pense que Madame Boinet
peut-être
surinterprète un peu l'influence qu'elle
a pu avoir dans ce dans ce domaine parce
qu'en tout état de cause la France
n'aurait pas obtenu une position
favorable donc
je crois qu'il y a peut-être là c'est le
moment où je vais dire quelque chose pas
de désagréable mais d'un pyronie un tout
petit brin devant tardise dans ce moment
là
de toute façon
taxinomie ou pas taxinomie intégré ou
pas dans le mécanisme de développement
propre qui ne concernait que les pays en
développement tout cela était sans aucun
effet sur le programme nucléaire
français sur sa suite donc je suis
obligé je ne devrais pas monsieur le
Président mais vous
répondre que je ne pense pas que c'est
le moindre effet sur la politique
nucléaire française contrairement à ce
que vous aviez
les suggérer
pour rester dans le domaine européen le
sommet de Barcelone en 2002 ouvre une
nouvelle étape notamment de l'ouverture
à la concurrence dans le domaine
énergétique c'est donc vous qui avez
préparé ce sommet
il est le fondement de la politique de
libéralisation des questions
énergétiques aujourd'hui
finalement quel bilan tirez-vous de la
position française de l'époque et des
choix qui ont été faits alors
s'il y a vraiment un fondement le
fondement c'est
1996 c'est la directive européenne
acceptée par le président Chirac c'est
le point de départ ensuite la loi 2010
c'est une loi de transposition dans le
droit français
d'une directive qui a été approuvée par
la France par le Président de la
République Jacques Chirac en 1996
j'ai dit tout à l'heure je vais le
redire de façon plus précise que dans la
loi de 2010 lois pierres dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure nous nous affirmons fait
une transposition dans le droit français
qui
comment dirais ce qui
[Musique]
instaurer une ouverture limitée du
marché puisqu'elle ne concernait que les
gros consommateurs
je précise aussi que cela ne remettait
pas en cause le service public de
l'électricité notamment dans ce qu'il a
sur un tarif unique sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
et que de ce point de vue aussi la
capacité d'investissement à moyen et
long terme de déesse ne se trouvait pas
obérée de la moindre façon donc je pense
qu'il n'est pas juste chronologiquement
de dire que le sommet de Barcelone ou
c'est vrai l'ouverture sa croix encore
nous sommes à la table de la de la
négociation la table française disons
avec le président Chirac donc ça on
ouvre au PME je crois
mais on est dans un processus qui
qui a été entamé avant dans lequel je
m'inscris et que nous et que nous nous
efforçons de limiter donc comme je l'ai
dit les lois de dérégulation qui ont été
prises après notamment de 2010
elle n'engage en rien le gouvernement
qui a été le mien
merci beaucoup j'en viens à la filière
électronucléaire française vous avez dit
dans votre propos liminaire que vous
l'avez restructuré et notamment
renforcer c'est la création notamment
d'Areva par la fusion de kojema et de
framatum
ma question elle est peut-être de
l'ordre un peu personnel mais à la tête
d'arriva vous vous installez entreprise
publique du coup vous installez madame
lovergeon comment ce choix
s'installe de mettre madame l'aubergeon
à la tête de cet outil industriel
comme vous le savez les décisions les
nominations importantes en cohabitation
sont prises par le Premier ministre et
le président de la République
parfois même les nobisations sont faites
par le Président de la République sur
proposition du Premier ministre donc
j'assume parfaitement la décision qui a
été prise à ce moment-là de la même
manière que c'est en accord avec Jacques
Chirac mais sur ma proposition que
François Roussely a pris la tête de EDF
dans cette période donc je n'ai pas de
commentaires à faire sur les raisons
pour lesquelles madame l'aubergeon était
parfaitement compétente et sur
lesquelles nous avons fait ces deux
choix l'un pour l'EDF l'autre pour Areva
et donc je ne vous je ne vois pas très
bien
[Musique]
en quoi je devrais motiver le choix que
le Président de la République et le
président et le Premier ministre
français ont fait à ce moment-là et
qu'elle est alors la feuille de route
que gouvernement confie à Madame
l'auvergon à la tête d'Arena
dans les grandes lignes vous avez un peu
parlé de la restructuration de la
filière électronucléaire on a découvert
enfin je crois que c'est de notoriété
publique que une forme de concurrence
entre EDF et Areva qui qui s'est
installé et qui a peut-être un peu
déstabilisé la filière électronucléaire
française est-ce que c'est quelque chose
dont vous avez déjà conscience qui vous
apparaît notamment sur la sur la fin de
votre de votre mandat ou c'est quelque
chose qui qui n'apparaît pas évident à
ce moment là
vous vous nommez à la tête d'entreprise
des dirigeants
dirigeantes qui ensuite développent des
politiques et il est vraisemblable que
arriva à penser à un moment qu'il était
lui-même qu'elle était elle-même en tant
qu'entreprise en mesure de concevoir
disons
un ensemble
nucléaire nouveau d'ailleurs par
ailleurs et donc
qu'ensuite les choix faits qui a eu
compétition
entre EDF et
arriva à ce moment-là
c'est vraisemblable que cette
compétition se soit nouée
les difficultés qui ont pu être
rencontrées par Areva en Finlande par
exemple
n'obéir pas non plus les difficultés que
EDF a pu éprouver dans la même situation
à propos de le père de Flamanville donc
ensuite là c'est des questions qu'il
faut que vous posiez
à ceux qui dirigeaient ces entreprises
elle ne résulte pas de façon logique ou
fatal des choix de nomination que vous
faites de votre personne qui par
ailleurs était parfaitement compétente
merci j'aurais deux dernières questions
la première sur le projet EPR du coup
qui existe
déjà et qui est construit sur la base
d'une commande forte de partenariat
finalement entre la filière
électronucléaire française et l'allemand
Siemens comment cette commande est-elle
est-elle posée dans quelle perspective
comment s'est construit cette idée de
mêler finalement Siemens à une filière
qui était quasi exclusivement française
mais
vous les
ce que nous avons fait nous pendant la
période où les les études qui étaient
menées par EDF et framatum sur la
perspective d'un nouveau type de
centrale à la fois plus efficace disons
avec un rendement supérieur du point de
vue énergétique et surtout peut-être
aussi avec un atout de sécurité
extrêmement renforcé ces études
existaient depuis un certain temps et
nous les avons elles se sont poursuivies
sous l'égide d'EDF et de Framatome
pendant la période où nous étions au
gouvernement
j'ai lu sur
Wikipédia je crois mais on est obligé de
s'y référer ça vous arrive parfois
que
nous nous saurions opposés
à l'ouverture d'une centrale EDF mais ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que pendant
la période où j'ai été au gouvernement
les études se sont poursuivies EDF et
Framatome ont travaillé sur ce qu'on
appelle le basique design disons
de d'un EPR et aucune entrave n'a été
mis à ses études la deuxième chose que
je peux vous dire c'est que les études
de sûreté qui accompagnaient bien
évidemment c'était la décine à l'époque
et l'IPSN les analyses de sûreté ont été
poursuivies également
nous n'avons
je n'ai aucun souvenir et nous n'avons
retrouvé aucune trace d'une demande que
de F nous aurait fait dans cette période
de lancer une procédure pour la
construction d'une centrale EP1 voilà
alors ensuite c'était
pas tout à fait la question c'est plutôt
la
surchimens
honnêtement nous avons constaté un
retrait progressif des Allemands
c'est pas nous qui avons introduit ces
minces dans la négociation très bien du
coup je pense que vous étiez en train de
répondre en partie à ce qui semble être
ma dernière question sur le projet qui
existait
qui semblait avoir existé au moment où
vous arrivez au gouvernement de création
d'une centrale au carnet on avale de
Nantes et qui qui ne verra jamais le
jour enfin d'un nouveau site est-ce que
c'est un un projet sur lequel vous êtes
intervenu on demandera EDF de ne pas de
ne pas le faire le maire de Nantes
semblait y avoir été opposé à l'époque
où c'est un projet qui ne sait voilà je
sais pas quel est le point de vue que
vous avez sur ce projet aucune
proposition de création d'un EPM par EDF
n'est venu dans la période où nous
étions en responsabilité donc je n'ai lu
ce qui avait des projets de Palli N4 par
exemple ou est-ce qu'il y avait des
projets d'autres types de réacteurs type
alien 4 ou
de création d'un site enfin je veux dire
j'ai le sentiment que il y a la réservé
un site pour y installer dans le futur
des moyens de production quels qu'ils
soient et puis à la demande de
construire à proprement parler des
réacteurs type EPR est-ce que l'ambition
pour de EDF de réserver un site pour un
développement futur existait et si oui
êtes-vous intervenu pour si elle
existait elle n'a pas été portée à ma
connaissance vous pourrez poser la
question à
si vous le convoquez
pour nous nous avions dans cette période
la perception que j'ai rencontré
quelques fois François Roussely qui ne
m'a jamais fait de demande donc ni
officieusement ni officiellement nous
n'avons été saisis d'une demande de
création enfin de préparation d'un site
pour l'installation future d'un EPR et
nous avions l'impression que dans cette
période EDF était
davantage préoccupé par ces problèmes de
maintenance du parc nucléaire d'une part
et d'autre part par son expansion à
l'international qui c'est d'ailleurs
manifester
et donc
mon sentiment était qu'à partir du que
Ed a fêté se satisfaisait que les études
soient menées qu'elles soient
accompagnées par des analyses de sûreté
pour être en mesure de lancer une
procédure d'installation de décision
d'installation de pair je dirais le
moment venu donc c'est c'est la
perception que j'ai moi de cette période
en tant que Premier ministre vous pouvez
compléter éventuellement sur celui qui
était en contact direct
par ailleurs
la décision de
lancement d'un EPR elle s'est faite
quand elle s'est faite en 2004
après et là
commencement des travaux de l'EPR de
Flamanville ont dû commencer en 2007
donc là aussi c'est déroulé quand même
après 2002 un certain nombre d'années
avant que les choses se concrétisent
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
oui
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre d'abord
pour votre disponibilité vous dire
l'honneur pour notre commission de vous
recevoir rue Edgar à vos responsabilités
et vous remercier de la grande clarté
des réponses que vous nous avez
apportées jusqu'ici je vais dans le
siège des questions du Président vous
posez une première question sur l'accord
électoral qui a été passé entre le Parti
socialiste et le parti les vert de
l'époque puisque le travail de notre
commission c'est bien de comprendre le
processus qui a mené aux décisions
prises en matière énergétique ma
question est simple le 1er mai 1997 dans
un entretien à la presse Dominique
Voynet évoque comme toute première
mesure qu'elle prendrait au sein d'un
gouvernement de gauche et d'écologie la
fermeture de super Phénix donc là la
question je pose c'est celle à l'ancien
responsable politique qui est en train
de négocier un accord politique lorsque
vous êtes en train de négocier cet
accord avec les verres et avec Madame
voilet quelle est la place pour les
verres de la fermeture de super Phénix
en termes de poids politique dans cet
accord parce que c'est important très
important est-ce que c'est un point non
négociable pour les verts ou est-ce que
c'est un point qui aurait pu être
négocié
je n'ai pas mené ces négociations il me
semble que c'est une personnalité
qui a une fonction extrêmement
importante aujourd'hui et qui a
été Pierre Moscovici qui a conduit ses
discussions mais en tout état de cause
sur ces questions sur lesquelles nous
travaillons
parce que à la direction du PS nous
il y avait aussi un groupe des experts
aux parties socialistes qui avaient été
créé par François Mitterrand très
antérieurement auquel j'avais participé
que j'avais recréé et qui travaillait et
nous avions un certain nombre de
personnalités à l'intérieur de ce groupe
des experts qui suivaient les problèmes
énergétiques et qui suivaient les
questions aussi scientifiques donc
au-delà de ce que nous avons découvert
et mis en œuvre quand nous avons été au
gouvernement déjà cette idée que
ce surgénérateur nous lui voyons pas un
avenir industriel
prospère cette idée elle existait dans
les cercles socialistes au niveau de sa
direction alors ensuite honnêtement
je sais pas je sais pas si c'est ces
propos que vous avez cité ou si c'est
votre transcription mais quand vous
dites la première mesure que je
prendrais au gouvernement ce serait de
fermer super Phénix honnêtement aucun
ministre fut-il de l'environnement et ne
l'était pas encore n'avait la capacité
de fermer superhénique
c'est une décision qui ne pouvait être
prise que par le gouvernement lui-même
et par le Premier ministre donc
ça ça fait partie des choses qui se
disent en politique mais en tout état de
cause nous
l'analyse que nous avons porté que j'ai
porté au niveau avec mes conseillers
à l'époque avec le ministre compétent
avec deux ministres oscan avec l'eau
d'Alègre avec Martine Aubrian un peu
pour des questions de sûreté avec
Christian Pierret lorsque nous étions au
gouvernement je parle nous ont conduit à
penser que cette filière ne pourrait pas
prospérer elle n'a d'ailleurs pas
prospéré depuis donc je sais pas
exactement dans quel terme vous posez le
problème mais nous nous pouvions aller
aux élections législatives sans en
accord avec les verres je me suis réjoui
qui a eu un accord avec les Verts mais à
aucun moment l'abandon de super Phénix
n'a été une condition de la réalisation
de cet accord et donc
voilà nous l'avons signé parce que cela
nous gênait pas de dire ça je peux vous
rappeler je vais vous dire une autre une
autre indication dans cet accord avec
les verbes du coup j'ai été amené à le
relire il m'avait un peu échappé il est
dit qu'il y aura un moratoire sur les
moches
il est dit qu'il aura remoratoire sur le
box
et nous avons boxé
dit
tranche nucléaire avec d'ailleurs
l'accord de Dominique
donc
vous voyez qu'il y a les accords il y a
les déclarations politiques ça a été
utile d'avoir un accord avec les verres
ça n'a pas posé de problèmes aux autres
parties prenantes de ce qui est devenu
la majorité plurielle qui préexistait
déjà à cette époque mais
ensuite il y a l'action gouvernementale
en tout état de cause donc
donc faut pas accorder
comment dirais à des décisions
politiques plus de poids qu'ils n'en ont
le micro
je vous remercie monsieur le Premier
ministre et je note donc que vous avez
dit que super la fermeture de super
Phénix n'était pas une condition
indispensable à un accord entre le Parti
socialiste et les Verts pas pour nous
non j'ai dit que c'était pas pour nous
un point fondamental
oui le jeu ne parle pas non
question en fait était très simple
c'était de savoir est-ce que pour les
vers alors vous dites que vous avez pas
été associé au négociations dans
l'accord psvers qui peut effectivement
paraître surprenant mais j'ai pas votre
expérience ce que vous dites c'est que
pour vous c'était pas un point dur dans
l'accord pS Les Verts ma question
c'était de savoir dans les négociations
si pour les Verts c'était un point dur
de la négociation pour pour conclure un
accord ou pas
je suis désolé mais je peux pas
m'exprimer au nom des Verts donc une
façon
en tout état de cause au bout du compte
vous y répondu y compris dans mon
intervention en anticipant sur le plan
on va dire politique à partir du moment
où nous étions d'accord pour prendre
cette position nous l'avons annoncé
publiquement dans un accord
en vue en direction des Français mais ça
comment dirais-je
d'une part je peux pas m'exprimer au nom
des vers et d'autre part le débat c'est
poursuivi aussi au sein du gouvernement
non pas sur la décision parce que la
décision était prise elle avait été
annoncée par moi elle était dans un
accord
elle avait été confirmée par moi mais il
y a eu un débat notamment avec plusieurs
ministres pour savoir dans quel délai
est-ce que cette décision était
irrévocable ou est-ce que on y viendrait
progressivement et ça a été finalement
arbitré notamment par mois pour dire que
on confirmait la décision qui avait
annoncé et celle qui était dans ma
déclaration politique générale par
ailleurs
c'est là Monsieur le Premier Ministre
que je dois vous exprimer mon désarroi
la décision de fermer super Phénix
figure dans un accord politique entre le
PS et les Verts vous dites que vous avez
au sein de la direction du Parti
socialiste suivi ce sujet de près du
fonctionnement de super Phénix vous
dites aussi que vous avez fermé super
Phénix vous avez décidé d'arrêter super
Phénix pour des raisons industrielles or
sauf erreur le deuxième tour des
élections législatives se tiennent le
1er juin 1997 le 17 juin 1997 en vote
déclaration de politique générale vous
annoncez la fermeture de super Phénix
vous êtes Monsieur le Premier Ministre
notre 43e audition
pour l'ensemble des personnes que nous
avons interrogées à l'exception de
Madame Lepage la fermeture de super
Phénix n'avait pas de fondement
industriel comment est-ce que vous avez
pu
en 16 jours avec l'ensemble des
administrations des entreprises des
industriels concernées prendre sur un
fondement industriel une décision qui à
tout le moins ne semble pas évidente
pour la quasi-totalité à l'exception de
Madame Lepage des personnes que nous
avons interrogées
cela veut dire que vous pensez sur la
base des auditions que vous avez auquel
vous avez procédé que les personnes qui
ont exprimé ce point de vue pensent que
aujourd'hui si super Phénix n'aurait pas
arrêté cette filière existe et
produirait de l'électricité en France
alors je
cela veut dire si je vous entends et
au-delà du désarroi que vous éprouvez
donc je pense que vous vous remettrez
je dois conclure de cheveux vous me
dites que à l'exception d'une personne
que vous avez cité indépendamment de la
perception que peuvent en avoir des
membres de la commission l'ensemble de
ces personnes pensent que aujourd'hui
une filière super Phénix
que Chris Malville fournirait de
l'électricité aujourd'hui en France
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est votre
opinion alors en tant que rapporteur de
la commission je rendrai un rapport qui
permettra d'exprimer ce que je pense je
vous dis simplement que c'est absolument
pas la question que je vous ai posé je
vous ai posé une question très simple
qui est sur quel fondement dit
industriel et auprès des décisions alors
que je ne que retracer et si d'autres
membres de la commission ne sont pas
d'accord avec ce propos je ne doute pas
qu'ils interviendront l'ensemble des
personnes à l'exception de Madame Lepage
que nous avions interrogé ont estimé que
la fermeture de super Phénix ne se
justifiait pas donc moi je fais
simplement ma mission de rapporteur qui
consiste à confronter les différents
points de vue que vous avez exprimé ne
retournez pas la question je vous
demande simplement si sur quel fondement
industriel en 16 jours entre votre prise
de fin ou un peu moins parce que
j'imagine que vous avez pas pris vos
responsabilités le soir du deuxième tour
en comment concrètement qui avez-vous
reçu quels sont les entreprises au-delà
d'EDF que vous avez pu interroger quels
conseils vous ont donné les conseils
ministériels les administrations sur la
base d'un fonctionnement industriel dans
le cadre ou en plus il était question
d'en faire un projet de recherche donc
ma question c'est simplement quels sont
les raisons qui ont présidé à ce choix
les raisons techniques industrielles
simplement c'était simplement une
question qui mettait forcément une
interrogation dans l'air puisque
l'ensemble de nos interlocuteurs ont
plutôt regretté la réalité je ne suis
pas en train de faire des conjectures je
vous pose simplement cette question
il y a une peut-être une mauvaise
habitude française ou dans certains
milieux français qui consistent à penser
que quelque chose qu'on a arrêté et donc
sur lequel on ne pourra pas porter un
jugement véritable au bout du compte sur
la validité de la filière en question
aurait été la solution miracle c'est
exactement la tonalité que j'ai trouvé
par exemple dans l'enquête entre
guillemets
qui apparu dans le point sur ce sujet
c'était le père le surgénérateur pas de
mémoire était la filière miracle qui
nous assurait la fin des déchets la
sécurité bon je ne tomberai pas moi
personnellement dans cette analyse et je
peux vous dire que l'équipe qui était
autour de moi était parfaitement en 15
jours à partir du moment où on avait
décidé que je le confirmais dans ma
déclaration du politique générale en
mesure
d'examiner les éléments techniques
scientifique et technique concernant
cette filière par ailleurs cette filière
et même l'article du point disait que
son développement avait été chaotique
cette filière
débouchaient sur des arrêts constants
commencez à avoir mais je vais répéter
mon introduction
coup de financier pour EDF considérable
et les développements ultérieurs n'ont
pas prouvé du moins dans les pays
développés sur lesquels il y a la
transparence sur ce qu'ils font ce
qu'ils ne font pas ce qui n'est pas le
cas des Russes que une telle filière
pouvait prospirer donc nous avons fait
dans le délai qui nous a été un parti
d'ailleurs la décision la mise en oeuvre
de la décision a pris plusieurs mois
ensuite donc ça ne s'est pas fait j'ai
fait l'annonce c'est-à-dire j'ai
confirmé ce qui était une décision
politique et fonder sur des éléments
industriels et techniques qui
confirmaient la validité d'autres choix
et nous l'avons fait dans le délai
j'avais auprès de moi un certain nombre
de domaines femmes d'une telle qualité
et j'avais aussi des ministres qui
étaient parfaitement capables de faire
une évaluation
dans le délai que vous avez évoqué
c'est-à-dire entre ma nomination et la
déclaration politique générale
je vous remercie une question qui émane
également de d'un rapport de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat relatif à
fermeture de superfélix pourquoi ne pas
avoir consulté par Le Mans sur une le
Parlement sur une décision aussi
importante pour notre filière nucléaire
parce que notre décision était prise
c'est pas consulté le Parlement pour
décider que nous engagerions les 35
heures j'ai pas décidé le Parlement
j'ai débattu avec le Parlement je vous
rappelle que dans l'époque où je
gouvernais la vie politique elle se
déroulait au Parlement elle se déroulait
entre le Premier ministre et les groupes
parlementaires les groupes
parlementaires de la majorité mais aussi
les groupes parlementaires de
l'opposition la scène centrale de la vie
publique française pendant les 5 ans de
mon gouvernement ça a été le Parlement
français donc je suis certainement à des
gouvernements qui a le plus non pas
forcément consulter le Parlement mais
engager des débats avec le Parlement à
partir des fondements qui articulaient
la politique de la majorité et à partir
des questionnements des critiques des
controverses engagées éventuellement par
l'opposition
donc
je n'avais pas à consulter le Parlement
pour lui demander de prendre une
décision qui de toute façon était de
l'ordre du pouvoir exécutif je ne sache
pas qu'il y ait une décision
parlementaire pour décider ou non de
l'arrêt de superficie
je vous remercie je reviens une question
un peu plus tardive enfin un peu plus
tard dans votre mandat en fait c'est une
question qui est issue d'un entretien
entre un ancien conseiller technique de
madame wannet monsieur laponge et un
journaliste sur la question d'un futur
européen qui serait construit vous avez
bien rappelé que vous n'avez pas eu de
proposition formelle il n'empêche si
j'ai bien suivi les débats de l'époque
que la question d'en construire un se
posait et ce conseiller relate la chose
suivante je voulais savoir si vous en
aviez souvenir si vous invalidez ou pas
ces propos est-ce que vous en pensez
il dit donc Madame Vanet est très opposé
à toute éventuel constructions à
futuropéen et il dit que Madame Vanet
vous aurait dit si tu le fais je
démissionne et je le fais savoir et ce
conseiller explique que dans les débats
de l'époque vous pensiez en vous citant
en parlant de vous comme il voulait la
garder comme il l'estimait en tant que
ministre et politiquement comme il
n'avait pas d'avis sur le Pr il a suivi
son avis
donc au delà de au-delà des phrases qui
n'ont pas un intérêt extraordinaire vous
en doutez je voulais avoir votre avis
est-ce que concrètement à un moment
lorsque la question s'est posée de
relancer la filière nucléaire même si
comme vous l'avez très bien dit il n'y
avait pas de proposition formelle est-ce
que concrètement les vers ont mis leur
poids politique dans la balance menacé
de démission pour la relance ou
l'avancée avec la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs
change qui a eu lieu semble-t-il entre
un conseiller et sa ministre
il est peut-il relater un échange entre
la
savoir si c'était si c'était
représentatif des échanges que vous avez
pu avoir avec Madame voilet ministre de
l'Environnement sur les questions
nucléaires vous comprenez bien ce qui
nous intéresse c'est pas les propos
exacts c'est de savoir si au sein de
votre gouvernement l'option
anti-nucléaire portée par les vers était
suffisamment fortes pour qu'ils mettent
en balance leur démission quand ce genre
de décision était à l'étude
le rapporteur je pensais avoir fait
justice de cette vision des choses dans
mon intervention est-ce que je dois vous
rappeler qu'il y avait huit députés vers
leur poids diminue tout d'un coup
brutalement qui avait 7 ou 8 députés
erreurs dans une majorité qui en
comportait plus de 300
d'autre part si j'avais mené comme vous
le laissez entendre à nouveau
oui mais vous laissez entendre par un
commentaire comme quoi j'aurais été le
poids des verres m'aurait amené à mener
une politique en tunnucléaire non
vous avez fait votre propre commentaire
alors d'accord alors bien
donc
le poids relatif des vers
dans la majorité plurielle était ce que
je vous ai décrit il y avait dans cette
majorité quatre parties et trois autres
partenaires en dehors du Parti
socialiste qui était favorable nucléaire
et qui aurait été donc opposé à une
politique qui aurait été anti-nucléaire
donc je pensais avoir clarifié cette
chose et c'est pas le propos supposé
entre un conseiller et sa ministre qui
devrait changer la tournure du débat sur
ce point
je vous remercie j'ai une question sur
sur un point que vous avez soulevé tout
à l'heure en soulignant les limites du
nucléaire à votre à votre sens vous avez
mentionné deux la question de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement avec l'idée
de diversifier le mix électrique et puis
la question des points et vous avez
semblé dire que le nucléaire
contrairement à d'autres sources
d'énergie mais je voulais que vous
reveniez dessus parce que je suis pas
sûr d'avoir compris ne permettait pas de
passer les périodes de pointe ou en tout
cas d'être activé en quatre pointes et
je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris en fait
pourquoi ce serait pas le cas pour
l'industrie nucléaire par rapport à
d'autres énergies
je répète que je ne suis pas un
technicien du nucléaire que je suis pas
ingénieur des mines
même si j'étais amené à travailler à
nouveau sur ces questions récemment
d'après ce qui m'a été dit la plupart
des autres pays nucléaires
utilisent peu
l'industrie nucléaire pour faire face à
ces moments dit de pointe et qu'il
préfère utiliser les autres sources
d'énergie d'après ce que j'ai compris ça
n'est pas que les centrales nucléaires
qui ont en principe des programmations
relativement longues quand même de
plusieurs mois ce n'est pas
qu'éventuellement on ne puisse pas les
faire fonctionner selon des cycles plus
courts mais j'ai cru comprendre de ce
qu'on m'en a dit que
ce serait peut-être
aux dépenses n'ont pas de leur sécurité
exactement mais ça serait les utiliser
dans des conditions qui ne sont pas les
meilleures du point de vue d'une
fonctionnement d'une centrale voilà ce
que j'ai compris puisque vous
m'entraînez sur un technique un terrain
technique ce que je vous reproche pas du
tout mais qui n'est pas directement de
ma compétence bien sûr donc voilà la
réponse à la question et donc d'autres
sources d'énergie
sont préférable semble-t-il comme
l'hydraulique ou le gaz
je vous remercie deux dernières
questions l'une simplement à nouveau
pour comprendre le contexte politique de
l'époque sur la le projet de bure enfin
sur le projet de de stockage est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire au sein de votre
gouvernement vous avez pris la décision
mais au sein de votre gouvernement
comment c'est comment s'est déroulée la
prise de décision est-ce qu'il y a eu
des oppositions
envisager un site de stockage de ce
point de vue est-ce que c'était
consensuel vous avez porté un projet
extrêmement important puisque de long
terme et qui qui méritait d'être lancé
tôt si on voulait qu'il ait une chance
de réussir souvenez-vous resituer le
contexte de la décision
quand nous avons abordé cette question
nous l'avons fait dans l'esprit de
l'essayer de d'avoir plusieurs options
qui restent ouvertes
le les difficultés que nous avons pu
avoir à l'époque ont été moins au sein
du gouvernement où il n'y en a pas eu
dans mon souvenir que dans les rapports
avec les collectivités locales avec les
élus et leurs degrés d'acceptation d'une
telle centrale ça ça a été quand même la
question qui nous a occupé le plus sur
laquelle nous avons dû travailler et
nous avons été heureux de déboucher sur
une possibilité
à Bure dans la Meuse
à l'intérieur du gouvernement
je dirais le ministre qui a
développé avec le plus de fermeté sa
position sur un point a été le ministre
de l'éducation nationale mais
spécifiquement là on l'espèce de la
recherche Claude Allègre qui était très
favorable à
un entrepôtement en surface des déchets
considérant sur le terrain de la
réversibilité que c'était évidemment ce
qui sur Outils
l'accès le plus facile en quelque sorte
et qu'à partir du moment où on
entreposait dans une certaine profondeur
même si on veillait à ce que la révère
les disciplines soit possible et je
rappelle que au stade actuel d'après ce
que je sais on en est toujours quand
même au travail de de recherche
d'expérimentation on n'est pas encore en
train de mettre véritablement
d'entreposer des déchets en tout cas en
nombre simplement pour et Claude Allègre
était favorable à cela ce qui de son
point de vue était
sans doute valable mais ce qui d'un
point de vue de sécurité alors on va
dire internationale si vous voulez était
plus discutable car effectivement ces
déchets par définition plus accessibles
mais ils étaient éventuellement plus
accessibles pour plus
donc au bout du compte le choix qui a
été envisagé
à emporter l'adhésion du gouverne du
gouvernement
je vous remercie une dernière question
qui concerne alors vous m'avez coupé
l'herbe sous le pied en disant que si on
parlait du rapport Pella vous auriez
peut-être pas tout vous souvenir mais
c'était quand même une question que
j'avais puisque en 2000 Jean-Michel
Charpin commissaire au Plan Benjamin
dessus directeur du programme au
scénario de programme au CNR c'est René
Pella au Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique vous remettre un rapport que
vous avez commandé sur les options
énergétiques du pays et d'ailleurs
notamment avec deux scénarios qui ne
sont pas sans faire penser à l'exercice
mené récemment par RTE notamment un
scénario de forte consommation à plus de
700 tterawattheure scénario de faible
consommation autour de 500 tt ma
question c'est étant donné la vision que
vous aviez pour la politique
industrielle de la France et la volonté
marquée on disait pas des carbonés comme
cette président mais de sortir autant
que possible des énergies fossiles
quel était votre vision de la politique
enfin des options à développer en
matière de politique énergétique pour
atteindre non pas seulement les
prévisions de consommation mais les
objectifs qu'on pouvait se donner en
termes de consommation d'électricité
pour continuer à réindustrialiser le
pays et est-ce que il y avait pas là un
delta franchir puisque on a beaucoup
parlé à l'époque de d'illusions sur
capacitaire en tout cas pour pour
certains de nos intervenants d'autres où
au contraire montrer que les enfin
d'autres intervenants ont d'autres
intérêts d'autres auditionnés pardon ont
plutôt évoqué le fait qu'on exportait
trop d'électricité et que donc il était
pas utile d'en produire davantage
quelles étaient vos réflexions
prospectives à l'époque à 20 ans 30 ans
pour essayer de combler le potentiel
besoin de production électrique ou
d'énergie décarbonée sur le territoire
c'était le l'opinion d'un certain nombre
de gouvernements
avant moi et après moi
d'estimer que
[Musique]
il y avait eu plutôt en raison de la
réaction puissante que j'ai rappelé tout
à l'heure au choc pétrolier de 1973 il y
avait eu sans doute une surestimation de
ce que serait les taux de croissance
économique dans le monde et en Europe en
particulier et aussi de ce que serait
donc la consommation d'électricité
ou d'énergie diverses à l'usage de
l'industrie et des transports dans la
période qui venait et donc plusieurs
gouvernements ont pensé que on était
plutôt
qu'on était sinon en surcapacité en tout
cas en capacité suffisantes
à tel point qu'un certain nombre de
gouvernements avant le mien et des
gouvernements après le mien ont évoqué
la nécessité de faire baisser le
pourcentage du nucléaire dans
la production électrique française donc
ce climat existait nous notre option ça
a été je ne me souviens je n'ai jamais
moi fait de déclaration disant qu'on
devait ramener le nucléaire à tel
pourcentage je me suis jamais exprimé
sur ces sujets
et donc notre approche c'était on
continue à développer le nucléaire nous
étions arriver à la fin d'un cycle des
centrales qui avaient été construites à
partir des années 70 nous pensions que
le Pr prendrait la suite mais
on était encore au stade des études et
comme je l'ai dit nous n'avions pas de
demande précise qui était formulée à
notre intention et puis nous avions
aussi l'espérance
de développer davantage les énergies
renouvelables si vous voulez
donc voilà il y a pas
je n'ai pas
comment dirais je n'ai pas souvenir d'un
moment où j'aurais défini ce que devait
être
l'équilibre et le et le degré de
développement de l'énergie
française sur les 30 prochaines années
merci beaucoup pour ces réponses aux
questions du rapporteur on va question
passer aux questions des députés membres
de la commission d'enquête en commençant
par le rassemblement national monsieur
Tanguy
bonjour Monsieur le Premier Ministre
écoutez je vous avais dit un moment que
vous avez estimé faire des choix pendant
votre mandat pour renforcer la
souveraineté énergétique je vais poser
plusieurs questions qui m'interpellent
par rapport au choix justement que vous
avez fait le vrai quand même revenir sur
votre échange avec le rapporteur sur
superhénix car en entendant vos réponses
mais aussi il me semble votre absence de
réponse j'estime qu'il reste une grande
confusion vous avez dit que vous n'avez
pas été vous avez pas arbitré dans le
programme ce point s'il est bien compris
avec Super Phénix ça a été renvoyé à
Monsieur boscovici mais tout à l'heure
dans votre introduction vous avez
pourtant dit que ce point avait été
soumis à l'arbitrage des Français donc
je comprends pas comment en tant que
chef de cette coalition vous pouvez
estimer que d'un côté vous n'allez pas
arbitrer mais que les Français l'ont
fait par ailleurs
j'étais assez jeune à l'époque mais je
me souviens pense pas quand même que
super Phénix était au cœur de l'élection
de 1997 et que c'était plutôt à mon avis
les enjeux social liés aux réforme Juppé
enfin je me sens quand même que c'est
consensuel en tout cas je me sens pas
que le prototype de quatrième génération
nucléaire était central dans l'élection
je ne dis pas qu'elle a été absente mais
pas centrale vous n'avez pas répondu il
me semble et je le vis en quand même en
support de ce qu'a dit le rapporteur sur
nos éditions l'ensemble des notamment
des techniciens de de des physiciens des
techniciens de nucléaire en tout
s'affirmé qui avait pas d'échec
industriels et technologiques de
superfices et c'est ça où se comprend
pas votre réponse puisque vous savez que
c'est super Phénix est un prototype
industriel donc affirmé que cette
perfenix doit être fermé parce qu'il a
un parcours chaotique d'un point de vue
d'ingénierie je trouve que c'est
aberrant puisque par définition un
prototype et chaotique et que plus
justement on avance que ce soit le
rapport du Sénat rapport de la Cour des
comptes ou les auditions que nous avons
fait plus on avance dans la dans
l'expérimentation ce prototype plus
justement la production est assurée plus
les défauts techniques sont corrigés et
justement vous le fermez par exemple à
un moment où une année vous annoncez la
fermeture ou la production d'électricité
de super Phénix est à son maximum avec
un taux de large de 35% qui est quand
même supérieur à beaucoup de moyens
d'électricité par ailleurs vous dites
que c'était une aberration financière
mais par définition l'ensemble des coûts
d'investissement super Phénix sont
réalisés au moment où vous décidez de le
fermer soit de mémoire 35 milliards 35
milliards de francs de l'époque que ça
fermeture va encore engager encore de
mémoire de 10 à 16 milliards de 16
milliards d'anciens francs enfin de
francs pardon
pour EDF et que par définition même avec
35% de charges moyens sur 40 ans on
pouvait dégager entre 300 et 400
millions de francs donc fermez super
Phénix alors qu'elle commençait à
fonctionner même en régime minimale
n'est pas pour moi un arbitrage
financier surtout que vous êtes
particulièrement alerte sur les
questions de finance et d'économie donc
je ne comprends pas comment vous avez
fait cet arbitrage dans le délai qui a
été évoqué par le rapporteur sans que
c'est des considérations politiques
c'est une question ce n'est pas une une
question comment dire une accusation
c'est une question ouverte j'essaie de
comprendre cette décision qui quand même
un coup pour la société de 10 milliards
d'euros de la même façon vous dites que
les sociétés occidentales n'ont pas pour
dans cette quatrième filière mais j'y
vois deux incohérences avec ce que vous
avez dit vous avez dit vous-même
qu'après les accidents nucléaires qu'a
connu les États-Unis et après Tchernobyl
avec des conséquences sur les opinions
occidentales nous assistons à une
fermeture du nucléaire et qu'en fait
d'une manière générale entre les années
90 et aujourd'hui nonobstant le père
dans le l'essentiel du design avait été
lancé avant il n'y a aucune percée
technologique dans le nucléaire
l'ensemble malheureusement enfin moi de
mon point de vue malheureusement des
démocraties occidentales ce sont retirés
de l'expérimentation industrielle de
nouvelles filières nucléaires et c'est
pas seulement la surgénération qui n'a
pas été exploité il n'y a aucune
recherche appliquée de nucléaire de 4e
génération dans aucun pays occidental et
malheureusement évidemment les tyrannies
que vous avez évoqué elle ont avancé et
nous ont pris notre avance et vous vous
semblez aussi ne pas faire ne pas
prendre en compte le fait que la France
avait une avance inédite
parmi les démocraties occidentales donc
le fait qu'aucune autre démocratie
occidentale n'est pris notre lait c'est
aussi parce que la France avait de
l'avance par exemple vous avez évoqué le
Japon mais le réacteur enfin la science
la physique japonaise sur la quatrième
génération dépendait justement du projet
français donc on ne peut pas reprocher
au Japon de ne pas avoir poursuivi
puisque nous-mêmes nous l'avons lâché je
ne comprends pas aussi quand vous dites
que c'est une filière qui n'a pas
espérer vous-même aussi vous considérez
qu'elle aurait dû prospérer par le
réacteur Astrid par le projet Astrid
nous vous regrettez l'abandon mais donc
c'est bien que vous considérez alors que
j'ai cru comprendre pardon que vous
regrettez l'abandon donc si j'ai mal
compris genre mon excuse mais en tout
cas que ce projet Astrid a été évoqué
que donc il y avait bien une suite à la
quatrième génération qui n'est
malheureusement n'a pas n'a pas enchaîné
sur un tout autre sujet il y a eu
beaucoup d'arbitrage sur votre sur votre
mandat de Premier ministre dans la
politique industrielle je voudrais en
évoquer notamment dans le problématique
est-ce que vous tenez absolument à poser
toutes vos questions
c'est l'usage
un effort de
noter oui mais mémoriser ça c'est moins
sûr
oui c'est tanti
notamment Alstom sous votre mandat des
décisions importantes d'une part le
commencement du démantèlement du
conglomérat Alcatel Alstom est-ce que
vous avez eu à connaître de ce début de
démantèlement sous monsieur de Fleurus
qu'est-ce que vous avez eu une opinion
notamment la privatisation de 52% de son
capital qui entraîné les suites que l'on
connaît ce que vous avez eu à connaître
de cette décision ce que
là j'ai plus la date mais c'est souvent
de mandat de les vérifier avant de vous
poser la question
je crois que c'est en 98 ou 99 ensuite
par exemple les décisions là j'ai des
dates très précises pour le sud d'Alstom
en 1999 Alstom décide de vendre à
General Electric c'est turbine de qui
sont produites
à Belfort pardon et suite à une
opération avec ABB opération avec ABB
opérateur Suisse à la chatte turbine
Suisse qui a mené Alstom à s'exposer à
des malfaçons sur cette turbine qui
entraîné les difficultés financières que
le groupe a connu en 2004 et 2005 le
début de son démantèlement est-ce que là
aussi vous avez eu à connaître des
décisions d'Alstom est-ce que vous avez
donné une opinion sur ce sujet votre
gouvernement ou est-ce que c'est des
opérations qui ont été fait sans votre
consentement de la même manière en 2000
framatum vend à genera électrique aussi
les activités thermodymes du Creusot qui
sont des activités extrêmement
importantes pour le nucléaire et pour la
flotte militaire une partie d'ailleurs
de cette de cette usine et sous secret
défense c'est de faire en 2000 est-ce
que là aussi vous avez eu à connaître de
ces décisions euh favorable au aux
Américains ensuite vous avez parlé de
l'opération que vous avez tout à fait
différent de secteur pétrole et gaz pour
essayer de favoriser pardon le
séquençage vous avez favoriser parler du
rapprochement entre ELF et total que
vous avez supervisé est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi vous
n'avez pas fait le choix d'un
actionnariat populaire ou même d'une
prise de participation importante de
l'État dans ce qui deviendra total qui
reste la plus grande entreprise
française pour les enjeux de
souveraineté que vous avez donné vous
avez parlé à sa tante de contrat
pétrolier susceptible de renforcer notre
souveraineté ces contrats et j'ai bien
noté été l'Iran l'Arabie Saoudite le
Venezuela
il me manque un mais c'était pas non
plus une grande démocratie est-ce que
vous estimez que c'est renforcé notre
souveraineté que de mettre notre destin
dans l'approvisionnement dans ces tirs
dans ces régimes autoritaires
et enfin c'est ma dernière question
monsieur le Président pour le rapport de
Kyoto voilà pourquoi est-ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur le choix
d'avoir pris comme date 1990 ce qui pour
me semble est une décision défavorable à
la France puisque l'effort de
décarbonation notamment de notre
électricité ce tient dans les années 80
alors que au contraire d'autres pays
notamment l'Allemagne
vont intégrer pardon l'Allemagne de
l'Est et donc on contracte une
difficulté à décarboner et qu'il aurait
été sans doute plus juste pour la France
d'intégrer dans le protocole de Kyoto
puis ensuite dans Paris l'effort de
décarbonation qu'elle avait fait et non
pas d'estimer qu'elle partait à égalité
avec des pays qui n'avaient pas fait cet
effort je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur Tanguy monsieur
le Premier ministre
oui ce qui est-ce qu'il est autorisé
dans la commission de poser une question
à celui qui vous questionne
avec son avec son accord bien sûr
vous poser une question est-ce que vous
pensez que aujourd'hui la filière super
Phénix si le
prototype
de Chris Malville
n'avait pas été arrêté et donc
progressivement démanteler est-ce que
vous pensez que cette filière
aujourd'hui aurait débouché qu'elle est
après avoir attendu un certain nombre de
gens quel est votre conviction sur ce
point est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
aurait débouchée
je sais pas monsieur le Premier ministre
si c'est de la rhétorique une vraie
question enfin si Monsieur Tanguy veut
réagir mais non c'est
comment pourquoi de la rhétorique parce
que nous faisons Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de la politique de part et
d'autre de ces noms
rien monsieur Tanguy est-ce que vous
souhaitez répondre
je pense monsieur le Premier ministre
sans être moi-même ni ingénieur ni
physicien que ce projet de prototype
quel était son avenir puisque
l'investissement essentiel initial avait
été fait aurait permis à la science et à
la technique d'avancer et la science et
la technique peuvent aussi avancer par
l'échec par l'imperfection et que tout
projet de recherche appliqué a un
intérêt quand il est suivi plusieurs
années et je peux vous citer beaucoup
d'exemples en physique qui sont nés
d'incident le petit accidents pour
paquet de malencontre de même mauvais
interprétation de ce que je vais dire
mais de hasard et par exemple si vous
prenez le cernes il y avait beaucoup de
découvertes océanes qui sont nées de
choses inattendues voilà et parfois même
un prototype peut donner des choses
imprévues et puis on tire des leçons de
tout mais en contraste qui est sûr c'est
que une filière ne peut pas naître quand
on l'arrête c'est le premier ministre
dans le domaine de la science je suis
prêt à vous à vous entendre le problème
de super Phénix c'est que c'était à la
fois un prototype de recherche et un
prototype dont la visée était
industrielle et donc dont les coûts
étaient considérables si vous voulez si
on était resté dans l'ordre pure de la
recherche pas les recherches ce serait
poursuivies
après tout on va bien poursuivre des
recherches à travers le processus ITER
si vous voulez sur la fusion et on ne
sait pas si cela débouchera en
2035 ou en 2045 donc on est dans un
processus là où des pays acceptent ils
sont nombreux de dépenser des sommes
effectivement mais qui sont celles
qu'incluent la recherche si vous voulez
dans une technologie future ou même dans
dans une dans une recherche je dirais
pas fondament qui est d'abord
fondamental
là il y avait un mix si vous voulez
c'était une Centrale qui avait été créée
c'est pas simplement un prototype
[Musique]
dans un dans un laboratoire quelquefus
sa taille donc je
reviens oui
donc je
[Musique]
les écoute l'écoute financier pour EDF
était absolument considérables et le
problème était que ce
prototype n'a pas été pensé
avec les industriels tout en devenant en
quelque sorte qu'elle une une
Centrale qui avait des objectifs
industriels et donc je pense que c'est
c'est notamment cela qui qui fait que
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit là
vous vous dites les problèmes étaient
réglés c'est une pétition principe
pardonnez-moi
très bien oui bon et donc c'est sinon
la validité de vos critiques je reçois
que j'entends
elle existerait si cette filière avait
prospéré ailleurs ce qui n'est pas le
cas alors vous argumentez à propos du
cas américain ou du cas japonais pour
dire mais c'est justement parce qu'on
n'a pas poursuivi qui n'ont pas
poursuivi les États-Unis ont absolument
les moyens de développer cette
technologie ici veulent la technologie
d'après ce que j'ai compris de mes
discussions récentes là avec un certain
nombre de ceux qui m'ont conseillé sur
ces questions et qui l'ont fait encore
c'est que les recherches
dans le domaine du nucléaire dont vous
dites d'ailleurs qu'elles sont très peu
nombreuses elles ne portent pas sur
cette filière aujourd'hui nulle part
quant aux Russes ce qui m'a été dit là
aussi d'abord on ne sait pas exactement
dans quelles conditions ils ont
développer ce sur générateur pas plus
qu'on ne le sait d'ailleurs pour la pour
la Chine parce que ce sont des régimes
opaques et d'autre part ce qui m'a été
dit à propos de la Russie compris par un
très grand expert du monde nucléaire que
je rencontrais il y a très peu de temps
c'est que les Russes de toute façon ils
travaillent surtout les filières
possibles
mais ce qui lui paraissait pas un signe
de la prospérité de cette filière c'est
que sur le surgénérateur ils ne sont pas
passés à l'échelon industriel
ils n'ont pas multiplié les
surgénérateurs et donc il le pensait que
même en Russie ça n'était pas probant
alors bon on va pas poursuivre peut-être
davantage un débat scientifique et
technique pour lequel niveau ni moi
sommes peut-être tout à fait préparé
mais je continue à penser et sauf à
tomber dans cette cette ce risque
français de considérer que ce aurait
absolument marché de façon phénomèneale
justement ce qui a été arrêté je pense
que les fondements sur lesquels nous
avons pris nos décisions d'arrêt de
super Phénix sont aujourd'hui encore
validées sur Astrid que je joins même si
c'était pas la question suivante
non j'ai pas regretté l'abandon d'Astrid
à aucun non mais aucun moment je n'ai
dit ça dans mon intervention tout à
l'heure pardon
d'Astrid j'ai dit que Astrid relancé en
2010 avait été abandonné je n'ai émis
aucun commentaire sur ce plan compris
parce que c'est la politique de mes
successeurs je le voyais plutôt comme un
argument la pile pour être clair bien
alors vous vous avez utilement quand
même à propos de la négociation avec les
Verts
lever une ambiguïté je n'ai pas procédé
aux discussions
qui ont été conduites en l'espèce par
Pierre Moscovici il me le rappelait
récemment mais naturellement j'étais
associé pleinement aux résultats et j'ai
évidemment approuvé la décision qui a
été prise il y a pas le moindre doute
là-dessus simplement j'ai pas
je vais pas vous rappeler à vous
parlementaire et membre d'un parti ce
que sont les discussions politiques mais
on discutait de l'énergie on discutait
des 35 heures on discutait des sièges et
donc il y avait un certain nombre de
responsables socialistes qui discutaient
sur ces différents secteurs si vous
voulez et moi je suivais naturellement
ces discussions et je les ai évidemment
j'étais évidemment informé et je les ai
approuvés donc la proposition que nous
avons fait au tour français elle m'avait
été clairement à moi rapporté avant je
lève un doute à cet égard et peut-être
que effectivement mon propos était tout
à l'heure peut-être un peu ambigu ou je
ne l'avais pas précisé vous avez dit que
la question de super Phénix par ailleurs
n'était pas au cœur des préoccupations
des Français oui et c'est vrai c'était
pas non plus au coeur de nos
préoccupations
au moment de l'accord politique en tout
cas en tant que conditions d'un accord
politique
sur
les autres
oui sur les autres pays non on en a on
en a dit un mot
Astrid aussi
la question démantèlement d'Alstom par
exemple là je me tourne vers vous moi
c'est la première fois que je viens
devant une commission d'enquête
personnellement et je n'ai pas eu comme
parlementaire à participer non plus à
une commission d'enquête et
donc
mais j'ai envie de vous dire à l'usage
de
des politiques en tout cas des
politiques qui ont été en responsabilité
relativement importantes
lorsqu'ils sont pas
le ministre compétent sur un secteur si
vous voulez mais qui sont été par
exemple comme moi Premier ministre ou
président de la République je crois que
vous avez envisagé dans de convoquer
peut-être
de recevoir bien des présidents de la
République ont un président de la
République je pense que si vous voulez
vraiment poser des questions techniques
et que vous voulez de la part de
quelqu'un comme moi dans la position qui
a été la mienne avoir une réponse
précise alors il vaut mieux nous la
transmettre franchement
sauf si c'est fait pour embarrasser bien
sûr mais je ne veux pas non non mais je
ne pouvais pas du tout donc c'est c'est
avec c'est en pleine bonne foi que je
vous dis ça si vous voulez donc si vous
voulez des réponses extrêmement précises
il faut les communiquer si vous voulez
moi qu'est-ce que je peux faire je suis
pas un technicien du nucléaire j'ai pas
été ministre de l'Industrie j'ai pas été
formé à l'École des Mines
j'ai présidé gouverné un pays j'ai
dirigé un gouvernement pendant 5 ans de
façon relativement efficace et de façon
en tout cas honorable j'ai eu à rendre
des arbitrages j'ai travaillé beaucoup
j'avais très bonnes équipes donc je me
suis imprégné de beaucoup de choses mais
je suis pas en mesure de répondre plus
de 20 ans après de façon précise à une
question technique sauf si elle m'a été
soumise à l'avance où quelqu'un se
répond donc pour d'autres pour d'autres
interlocuteurs qui se trouveraient
éventuellement dans ma position je vous
suggère cela
par contre
je suis si j'ose dire un de vos pères
c'est à dire un ancien homme politique
un ancien élu du peuple et un ancien
responsable des temps
et sur ce terrain par contre
j'ai un certain nombre de choses
éventuellement à dire certaines que j'ai
pu dire d'autres que je n'aurai pas
l'occasion de dire parce qu'elles m'ont
pas été posées et mon objectif à moi ce
que je peux peut-être faire c'est pour
vous éclairer sur les motifs de nos
choix et sur les actions que nous avons
menées c'est pas forcément de répondre à
tel ou tel point particulier
que vous pouvez soulever sauf si vous
nous en parlez
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour
les socialistes et apparentés madame
Baptiste
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
merci beaucoup pour toutes les
informations très précises que vous nous
avez apporté et qui témoignent d'un gros
travail de récupération d'éléments que
vous avez fourni et d'une grande mémoire
des différentes événements qui ont
conduit un certain nombre de décisions
j'ai envie de dire que moi je veux
retenir de cette période sur laquelle
nous travaillons de 97 à 2002 peut-être
quelques choses positives puisque dans
cette commission d'enquête nous sommes
là aussi pour dire ce qui a conduit ou
pas
à la perte de souveraineté de la
énergétique de la France mais aussi de
dire ce qui a pu conforter la
souveraineté énergétique de la France à
un moment donné
moi j'aurais souhaité insister sur un
apport important de votre mandat qui est
le renforcement et la centralisation des
administrations chargées du contrôle des
installations nucléaires avec la
création en 2002 de la direction début
2002 de la direction générale de la
sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection qui reprend les
activités de la direction de sûreté des
installations nucléaires du bureau des
rayonnements de la Direction générale de
la santé d'une partie de l'Office de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants et de la commission
interministérielle des radios élément
artificiels tout cela préfiguré la
création de l'ASN devenu autorité
administrative indépendante en 2006 en
2006 une autorité extrêmement précieuse
et incontournable aujourd'hui et je
pense depuis sa création dans le suivi
de nos installations et sur laquelle
nous nous reposons pour l'ensemble
décision concernant la filière et je
crois que cet instant crée aussi la
confiance que l'on peut avoir dans le
nucléaire français et je tenais à le
souligner
cette démarche a permis également
d'avoir un regard et un contrôle
indépendant des DF en entendant qu'il
soit indépendant du pouvoir politique
dont on mesure l'importance dans le
contexte de la réflexion autour d'un
nouveau programme de PR du grand
carénage de la prolongation au delà de
50 ans de la vie des centrales et du
suivi des cas de corrosion sous
contrainte sur la question de l'absence
de lancement de nouveaux projets de
construction sous votre mandat notamment
le lancement de projet EPR
vous êtes souvent défendu en rappelant
qu'à la fin de votre mandat le réacteur
en service le plus ancien faitsenheim
n'avait que 24 ans et donc que la
question du remplacement de ces
centrales n'était pas forcément encore
posée pour autant il a vous avez
poursuivi les études sur le programme
EPR vous avez très longuement lors de
cette réduction à plusieurs reprises
parce que vous y avez été invité de
nombreuses fois vous avez assumé
l'abandon du programme super Phoenix au
regard de choix politique vous l'avez
dit mais aussi on vous appuyant sur
l'immaturité des technologies mises en
oeuvre et de la non viabilité économique
qui souligne d'ailleurs que l'abandon en
2019 du premier Astrid confirme
peut-être votre analyse initiale et vous
donne raison
je crois que nous avons pas eu le même
retour que le rapporteur tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il disait qu'il y avait
l'ensemble des personnes auditionnées
qui avaient considéré que cette décision
ne reposer que sur du choix politique et
pas sur un choix industriel je crois que
ceux qui l'ont dit en tout cas que
c'était un choix politique non pas
écarté le fait que il y ait aussi des
éléments industriels qui permettaient de
poser la chose mais je n'ai pas assisté
à toutes les auditions donc je ne
m'avancerai pas pour dire que
qui a raison en la matière
[Musique]
oui vous avez également initié sous
votre mandat de manière assez pionnière
un plan de développement des énergies
renouvelables avec notamment l'adoption
du programme national de lutte contre
l'effet de serre qui fixait un objectif
de 3000 mégawatts en électricité
éolienne un virage à l'époque pas si
naturel donc ça c'est ma première
question avant d'avoir déployé un
certain nombre d'éléments qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à l'époque à cette
évolution à cette direction et
pensez-vous à cette époque là que 20 ans
plus tard c'est-à-dire 20 même presque
25 ans plus tard alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui nous serions en train de
voter un texte d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables que nous voterons
dans une demi-heure parce que nous
n'avançons pas sur ces sujets là
enfin sous votre mandat c'est souvent de
mandat qui a été pris le décret
obligeant les distributeurs
d'électricité à racheter l'électricité
produite à partir d'énergie
renouvelables pour toutes les
installations d'une puissance inférieure
à 12 mégawatts un mécanisme qui a évolué
depuis par les différents textes
notamment la loi de transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
mais qui a permis de à la fois
conforter les les installations
d'énergie renouvelables mais aussi à
l'inverse aujourd'hui de contribuer à
des recettes qui reviennent dans les
caisses de l'État et de payer une partie
du bouclier tarifaire
tout cela participe également de la
souveraineté énergétique de la France et
si je peux encore une toute petite
seconde monsieur le Président
dire que finalement
on regarde ce que vous vous avez
développé vous avez à plusieurs reprises
évoquées le souci permanent en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai ressenti de veiller à
ne pas mettre en danger financier et en
tout cas d'équilibre économique et DF
pour qu'ils soient en capacité de
maintenir finalement un autre
souveraineté énergétique et de
contribuer à
la péréquation tarifaire et on a assuré
l'énergie pour tous les Français je suis
sur la question également de la loi de
96 qui a été décidé sous la présidence
Chirac vous avez rappelé que c'est en
2010 que cette loi de transposition en
droit français avait finalement instauré
la mise sur le marché de l'électricité
qui écarte finalement qui occulte
l'ensemble du mandat sur lequel vous
étiez responsabilité est-ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser si ces sujets là
étaient évoqués pendant votre mandat et
s'il y a eu des tentations de cette de
prendre cette direction qui a été
finalement prise en 2017 merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame Baptiste pas de
souci monsieur le Premier ministre
il y aurait d'un système sur un point
qui n'est qui peut venir dans la
discussion même s'il a été
effloré c'est
l'indépendance du contrôle de la de la
Sûreté Nucléaire ça je pense que ça a
été une décision absolument fondamentale
à la fois parce que il était nécessaire
pour une industrie aussi particulière
que nous soyons certains que il ne
pouvait pas y avoir de conflits
d'intérêt quand il s'agissait de la
sécurité des sites et de la sécurité des
Français et que derrière qui devaient y
avoir une séparation entre ceux qui
faisaient l'étude prenaient les
décisions assurer les fonctionnements
des centrales et ceux qui étaient
chargés de dire si la sécurité était
assurée je pense que ça a été un pas en
avant considérable qui a pu être
critiqué à ce moment-là notamment par
ceux que de façon un peu trop indistinte
on appelle parfois le lobby nucléaire
mais qui s'est révélé une décision
extrêmement importante positive
et qui d'une certaine façon à légitimer
l'option nucléaire parce que on a
beaucoup fait allusion s'étend dernier à
ce que pensait l'opinion et beaucoup
disent que actuellement l'opinion
française est plutôt favorable au
nucléaire mais il y a eu des moments où
l'opinion française était défavorable au
nucléaire ou plus exactement parce qu'il
y a toujours eu je crois une majorité en
sa faveur mais exprimait tout d'un coup
des doutes et une incertitude à propos
du nucléaire et évidemment quand vous
vous situez après
le
Tchernobyl ou quand vous vous situez
dans la guerre en Ukraine alors que les
prix des produits pétroliers flambent
vous n'avez pas le même contexte
l'opinion elle a pas les connaissances
des experts mais elle réagit avec une
forme de bon sens
si il y a un accident
nucléaire c'est que cette
filière que cette production peut être
dangereuse si les prix du pétrole flambe
alors il est particulièrement important
que nous puissions recourir à l'énergie
nucléaire qui nous rend pas dépendant
sauf pour l'uranium et encore il y a des
évolutions des des puissances étrangères
donc l'opinion bouge et je pense que de
ce point de vue
par rapport aux Français c'est
indépendance de la de des
des autorités de contrôle
et est absolument est une décision qui a
été fondamentale
sinon oui vous avez dit je pense aussi
que
à l'époque
à l'époque où nous avons été au
gouvernement le remplacement de
centrales et la création nouvelle
centrale effectivement ne semblait pas
s'imposer compte tenu de ce qui était
l'évolution de la consommation et de la
production et quand tout est à être
causes il était plus
rationnel de se fonder sur ce que serait
les nouvelles technologies c'est-à-dire
le Pr
[Musique]
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour
opécologie et vert madame lernos
oui
merci monsieur le Président je crois que
c'est la première fois que vous me
présentez ainsi mais peut-être que c'est
le contexte de cette audition plus
politique qui permet de
c'est tombé sur vous si
mais certains d'auditionnés avant vous
nous avez demandé aussi peut-être
d'avoir des chevalets effectivement pour
mieux pouvoir nous identifier lors des
auditions et voir à qui ils avaient à
faire
avec nous sommes là aujourd'hui dans une
nouvelle forme d'audition puisque
monsieur le Président et monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez pris comme source
notamment une vidéo du lobbyronucléaire
qui est rappelé ici pour poser une
question des propos rapportés de
Monsieur laponge qu'on aurait pu
auditionner
et ça aurait pu être pertinent serait ce
que ça aurait fait peut-être une
personne qui était ouvertement
anti-nucléaire et qu'on a on s'est
concentré
euh à auditionner des personnes qui
étaient plutôt favorables aux nucléaire
et puis je me suis Armand vous avez
généralisé des propos des auditionnés
quand à super Phénix il me semble que
quand on reprend la liste des auditions
monsieur Brichet du CEA renvoie un livre
monsieur escatar envoie EDF monsieur
combombani dit rien sur les aspects
techniques monsieur fervard a pas voulu
répondre vous avez vous avez un ancien
Premier ministre nos questions
de parole pour vous adresser au
président et aux rapporteurs libre à
vous mais ne venez pas vous plaindre
ensuite quand le temps de la Réunion
découlera et qu'on en reviendra vous
demander de conclure il me semble que un
point majeur qui était à l'origine de la
discussion et des propos qui ont été
portés pour essayer de faire dire que
aucun acteur n'avait évoqué des
problématiques techniques financières et
juridiques liés à l'arrêt de super
Phénix et en fait monsieur l'ancien
Premier ministre a été auditionné pour
savoir si c'était le poids des
écologistes et des accords électoraux
qui avaient prédominé et non des choix
techniques rationnels et juridiques sur
lequel nous avons été éclairés sur
lequel le Parlement il me semble dans
différentes commissions en 98 aussi
permis de s'exprimer de donner son avis
qui vont dans le même sens notamment sur
les coûts ce qui mène à une question
dans une récente interview au point vous
avez dit quand je gouvernais nous
n'avons jamais fait les poches de cette
grande entreprise pour assurer la fin
des mois du budget de l'État
contrairement à d'autres après nous
alors là vous avez peut-être dérogé à
votre règle que vous êtes fixé
précédemment c'est à dire de ne pas
porter de jugement sur ce qui s'était
passé après vous mais j'aurais aimé
avoir votre éclairage sur
en tout cas la manière dont vous avez
traité EDF est peut-être cela
explique-t-il aussi en plus des soucis
juridiques et techniques il y avait sur
superhénix et qui ont mené à leur arrêt
en plus de l'accord avec les Verts et
est-ce que l'accord des accords
électoraux à votre sens sont uniquement
des accords électoralistes ou est-ce que
ça permet aussi entre plusieurs
formations politiques de discuter du
fond d'un certain nombre de
problématiques de sujets de société et
d'apporter des éléments et des
éclairages techniques et rationnels qui
emmènent et qui entraîne une décision
quelque part collective sur un certain
nombre d'aspects dont par exemple
l'arrêt de superficie qui avait subi des
défauts techniques majeurs successifs et
dont le Conseil d'État venait également
de d'annuler le décret d'autorisation de
redémarrage et donc est-ce que
dans les accords politiques souvent on
entend politiciens est-ce qu'il y a pas
aussi quelque chose de noble à
confronter les idées et avoir un accord
là-dessus une question sur la dépendance
et la souveraineté énergétique dans vos
propos liminaires vous avez au moment
d'évoquer
souveraineté et dépendance indépendance
énergétique de la France vous avez mis
des guillemets
vous l'avez affirmé d'autres
auditionnées ont interrogé cette notion
d'indépendance et de souveraineté
énergétique pour savoir si elle existait
réellement dans la mesure où nos
énergies fossiles sont toutes importées
aujourd'hui l'uranium et 100% importé et
donc il y a une interrogation sur ce
terme qui est employé et donc vous avez
fait état dans vos propos également de
différents contrats bilatéraux et
diversification des contrats avec
différents états pour justement assurer
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'État français cela ne vaut pas est-ce
que cela pour vous vaut indépendance et
souveraineté énergétique c'est une vraie
la question là sur la terre le terme et
la définition sur les énergies
renouvelables votre gouvernement
s'est-il concentré sur
l'hydroélectricité à votre sens et
est-ce que cela vous avez évoqué le fait
qu'il y a eu le début d'une filière en
tout cas de l'installation d'éolienne le
début et on n'est pas du tout dans la
même époque non plus des panneaux
photovoltaïques mais il semble que dans
les énergies renouvelables est-ce que il
y avait une tendance à dire que
l'hydroélectricité plus le nucléaire
était suffisant en termes de énergie
décarbonée de l'État français une
dernière question qui n'a pas été
évoquée c'est la diminution de la
consommation
en tout cas les efforts en termes de
transition écologique sur la réduction
de notre consommation puisque là aussi
on voit si on veut tendre à accroître
notre indépendance énergétique de
consommer moins ça nous rend aussi la
moins dépendant et vous l'avez pas du
tout évoqué dans
nouveaux propos donc c'était une
question aussi est-ce que ça avait été
un souci ou une préoccupation majeure ou
non
merci beaucoup madame lernos
monsieur le Premier ministre
je sais plus j'ai peut-être pas mis ça
dans un ordre visant
en vous entendant je pensais à une
question accompagnée d'une remarque par
le précédentes intervenant à laquelle
j'ai oublié de répondre qui était le
fait que dans les désaccords d'achat de
pétrole fait dans un certain nombre de
pays on comptait l'Arabie Saoudite le
Venezuela
et l'Iran par exemple prendre que ces
trois-là
honnêtement compte tenu de ce qui est ce
que sont les producteurs
de gaz et de pétrole aujourd'hui
si nous devions déterminer nos
politiques énergétiques simplement sur
le fondement de savoir si les pays qui
exportent du pétrole et du gaz sont des
pays démocratiques ou en tout cas
supportables
je crois qu'on aurait un vrai problème
d'approvisionnement en produits
pétroliers et je ne sais pas comment on
s'en passerait si vous voulez
donc alors il y a des périodes de
contexte aussi il y a des moments de il
y a des périodes qui créent un contexte
je pense que on ne signerait sûrement
pas un accord avec l'Iran aujourd'hui si
nous étions aux responsabilités au
gouvernement c'est évident à l'époque où
ça a pu se passer le régime
des ayatollah était le même
l'oppression était également
considérable mais on n'était pas face à
des moments de répression violente donc
honnêtement
l'Arabie Saoudite un certain nombre de
pays de la péninsule arabique le
Venezuela
qui n'était d'ailleurs pas
le même régime qu'aujourd'hui je le
rappelle c'est
c'est quand même des choix auxquels tout
gouvernement ou toute formation
politique et aspire à gouverner serait
confronté très vite si elle devait
utiliser vos critères donc je voulais
répondre sur ce point alors pour revenir
à Madame vernis
pardon vers nous
d'accord très bien donc je suis pas sûr
d'avoir construit tout dans dans le bon
ordre
effectivement sur EDF
c'est un moment où je me suis un peu
laissé aller dans la réponse au point
parce que
la mauvaise foi de cette enquête
m'avait un petit peu agacé et donc comme
là je n'avais pas
je n'avais pas à m'imposer
l'arrêt que je me suis fixée devant la
commission
j'ai dit en tout cas nous n'avons pas
fait la poche des poches de DFS que dans
la période je voulais faire vérifier
dans la période où j'ai été au
gouvernement nous n'avons jamais demandé
sous quelques formes que ce soit un
financement
c'est pas le cas depuis
avoir des raisons qui peuvent être
apportées mais c'est pas le cas depuis
quand nous étions aux responsabilités
pendant 5 ans
l'endettement de DF était en moyenne de
25 milliards d'euros il est aujourd'hui
actuellement de plus de 5 ans je crois
bon donc voilà c'est le seul élément de
non pas de réponse mais de réaction à
votre à votre remarque que je ferai nous
avons permis à EDF de travailler et en
tout cas nous ne l'avons pas imposé
d'aucune façon financièrement y compris
pour finir
des fins de mois budgétaires
j'étais un peu surpris moi aussi
à la fois de je le dis très franchement
non pas les vocation de cette vidéo
puisque je m'y attendais un peu mais
notamment de cette conversation entre un
conseiller et une ministre qui
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez dit
non
en tout cas ce qui était dit dans ce qui
était j'ai cru comprendre comme c'était
quand même ce que disait un conseiller
non
c'est que disait un conseiller à propos
d'une conversation supposée entre la
ministre et moi c'est ça bon donc
c'était bien le propos d'un conseiller
ce propos d'un conseiller était associé
à sorti de commentaires y compris
sûrement
je m'attendais pas je dois dire à une
question de ce niveau mais j'ai essayé
d'y répondre
et donc
je pense que
sur un certain nombre de questions et
par exemple sur
le surgénérateur les vers peuvent dire
des choses juste
pour moi ils ne sont pas à critères j'ai
répété qu'il n'avaient pas pesé de façon
décisive sur les décisions qui ont
concerné le nucléaire et je ne vois pas
un point sur lequel vous pourriez dire
que je mets à part super Phénix si je
veux dire pendant la période de
gouvernement je vois pas un point sur
lequel ils auraient freiné le programme
nucléaire français et même sur Super
Phénix puisque l'axe central de votre
commission c'est de rechercher les
raisons pour laquelle il y a une perte
d'indépendants de souveraineté et
d'indépendance de la France
donc c'est ça qui vous guide et c'est à
ça que je dois répondre le fait que nous
ayons arrêté super Phénix
n'a en rien privé la France d'une
portion de sa souveraineté ou d'une
portion de son indépendance en rien et
je ne vois pas comment on pourrait faire
la démonstration inverse sauf à retomber
dans ce que je disais tout à l'heure
puisque cette filière a été arrêtée et
qu'on ne peut pas démontrer
qu'elle n'aurait pas réussi alors elle
était la filière miracle donc cette
façon d'aborder les choses m'a un petit
peu surpris sur
indépendance et souveraineté j'aurais
tendance à dire et j'ai mis les mots
entre guillemets parce qu'ils étaient
dans l'intitulé de
de la Commission elle-même donc c'est
pourquoi c'était une citation en quelque
sorte de ces deux mots mais les
guillemets ont un autre sens aussi parce
que ils introduisent une notion de
relativité si vous voulez
et c'est vrai que
l'indépendance ou l'indépendance elle
est quand même moins relative que naît
la question de la souveraineté c'est à
dire que
elle a une dimension plus objective
et long terme c'est pourquoi vous les
avez bien choisis qui est de la
souveraineté pour lequel j'ai employé le
mot ou le verbe il faut la construire
c'est la façon ou dans une situation où
il y a un inévitable degré de dépendance
mais en même temps une volonté
d'affirmer une indépendance sur un
certain nombre de points la souveraineté
c'est au fond la manière dont les
responsables politiques au nom du peuple
souverain en quelque sorte s'efforce de
construire la souveraineté de la France
dans les conditions qui pour la France
ne sont pas les plus favorables compte
tenues de l'absence de son charbon de
son pétrole de son uranium donc je pense
que c'est le fait de revenir sur cette
distinction entre les deux mots et et
tout à fait pertinente
sur les économies
oui dans le plan notamment
qui qui a été développé par Dominique
ouannin sur le plan territorial
notamment dans le cadre des contrats est
en région si vous voulez ou de dans les
dialogues avec la municipalité les
municipalités la dimension des économies
d'énergie était extrêmement présente
Jean-Claude guesseau qui était le
ministre des Transports pendant toute
cette période de l'équipement et des
transports a également été extrêmement
sensible à cette dimension et dans les
accords là aussi qui ont été partis
passer la volonté d'économiser l'énergie
en direction des
différents interlocuteurs et des
consommateurs a été une diminution une
dimension importante de notre de notre
travail et de notre vision des choses
juste une dernière question plus
contextuelle vous l'avez dit je crois
dans votre propos liminaire
ce sentiment que l'énergie était un
sujet de technicien et devient un sujet
politique est-ce que c'est un élément du
contexte de l'époque où vous avez
gouverné qui vous semble aujourd'hui
marquant ce fait que l'énergie passe
progressivement de d'un sujet technique
à un sujet de débat politique où est-ce
que c'est un regard qu'on a aujourd'hui
et qui est un petit peu four considérant
finalement l'énergie a toujours été un
sujet de débat politique
non ça a toujours été un sujet de débat
politique dans la référence que j'ai
faite à au contexte historique dans
lequel
s'est développée notamment l'industrie
nucléaire
et aussi à propos des questions
énergétiques en général ou de façon plus
large je pense que ça souvent ça
toujours été une dimension de la
souveraineté des nations une question
essentielle pour le développement
industriel
qui évidemment colorée maintenant par
les conséquences de ce développement
industriel
depuis plus de deux siècles si vous
voulez avec notamment les problèmes du
réchauffement climatique et c'est ce qui
fait que c'est une question
centrale pour les pour les gouvernements
et que j'ai considéré comme tel
pour cela à mon sens
et donc
croire que parce qu'il y a eu des vers
dans le gouvernement ça nuit à la
politique énergétique de la France que
saurait mis en cause le consensus par
exemple sur le nucléaire je crois le
contraire je pense que le fait qu'une
formation politique écologique et
participer à un gouvernement pendant 5
ans lequel a continué à développer la
filière nucléaire je pense que ça a été
ça a montré que y compris des forces qui
avaient été jusqu'ici étrangère
à cette vision et aussi à la
responsabilité le fait qu'elles aient
été intégrées dans un dans un
gouvernement au niveau du pouvoir d’état
je pense que ça a été une bonne chose et
pour revenir un instant sur Dominique
Vanet Dominique Voynet au-delà de tel ou
telle vidéo dont vous avez eu raison
Madame de rappeler que
celle qu'il a fait
pas étrangère à certains lobbys au-delà
de ça je veux dire que Dominique bonnet
d'abord c'est une femme rationnelle
c'est un médecin elle a une culture
scientifique et elle analyse les
problèmes de façon rationnelle c'est
l'expérience que j'en ai eu la deuxième
expérience que j'ai eue c'est que elle
n'a pas renoncé à ses convictions
pendant la période où elle était au
gouvernement mais elle était réaliste
elle était consciente
pendant la période elle a été au
gouvernement parce que elle n'est pas
partie pour
à propos de c'était de l'EPR non c'est
ça
c'est différent bien et donc pendant la
période où
Dominique vanner a été au gouvernement
elle n'a pas renoncé à ses convictions
mais elle était réaliste consciente du
rapport de force et donc elle a
accompagné une politique en essayant de
donner des accents dans un certain
nombre de domaines et donc le souvenir
que j'ai d'elle c'est d'une ministre et
d'une femme loyale quelle que soit
l'impression qu'a pu donner à certains
une vidéo
qui a essayé de faire de quelqu'un
quelque chose qui n'avait aucune
importance
la preuve de je ne sais quelle
démonstration
ma question était vraiment d'ordre
général sur la place de l'énergie dans
le débat public je crois que vous l'avez
vous l'avez dit vous avez plusieurs fois
dans vos réponses aborder la question du
contexte qui me semble importante et
quand on essaye de faire ce travail de
compréhension du processus
comprendre le contexte de l'époque dans
lequel les décisions étaient prises me
semblent importants du coup j'aurais
peut-être juste une appréciation sans
que ce soit sur la les choix de vos
successeurs
mais en parallélisme finalement l'époque
où vous vous dirigez le gouvernement est
une époque où on fait la transparence on
fait plus de consultation des citoyens
sur la question notamment du nucléaire
en tant que président de la plus
ancienne commission locale d'information
et de surveillance qui existe en France
je ne peux que témoigner de la nécessité
de la transparence et de l'information
en la matière nucléaire mais est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment qui est une forme
de parallélisme
qu'on aurait peut-être pas pu penser à
l'origine mais qui est nécessaire aussi
dans toutes les énergies y compris
peut-être les énergies plus diffuses qui
n'ont pas de risque en matière de sûreté
mais qui semble dans notre pays créé un
problème d'acceptabilité
aujourd'hui et est-ce que sur ces sujets
là aussi une logique de transparence
finalement une vingtaine d'années après
que ça apparaisse parallèlement
nucléaire serait nécessaire
à partir du moment où il y a des
problèmes d'acceptabilité par exemple
c'est sur les éoliennes si vous voulez
ou sur certaines certains projets de
barrage j'ai hydraulique j'ai connu ça
dans ma région si vous voulez compris
quand j'étais député et que j'ai présidé
pendant un temps l'Institut
l'Institut interdépartemental de la
Montagne Noire qui faisait de
l'aménagement hydraulique partir de ce
moment-là oui la transparence qui ne
doit pas empêcher ensuite la décision
des responsables si vous voulez elle est
utile dans quel que soit les formes
d'énergie naturellement et c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être une des conditions
de lactée de l'acceptabilité
très bien
très très vite monsieur Tanguy parce
qu'après il y a un vote j'aimerais pas
reprendre après
et merci monsieur le Président je suis
désolé de supprimer mais j'ai posé un
certain nombre de questions très
précises sur la politique industrielle
sous votre mandat vous avez répondu avec
une généralité qui correspond pas je
vous ai pas demandé des détails je vous
ai pas demandé si l'URSSAF est intervenu
sur une PME je vous ai parlé du
conglomérat Alstom Alcatel qui était je
vous rappelle à l'époque dans le top 5
des plus grandes multinationales
industrielles du monde avec 75 000
employés c'est quand même pas des
décisions industrielles déléguées à
quelqu'un je n'arrive pas à croire qu'en
tant que Premier ministre vous n'ayez
pas eu connaissance des décisions d'un
tel groupe en France quand la France
sacrifie cette turbine à gaz j'ai du mal
à croire que vous n'êtes pas au courant
quand vous sacrifiez des turbines qui
font fonctionner la flotte militaire
aussi bien les sous-marins que que les
bateaux de surface n'arrive pas à croire
que que vous n'êtes pas au courant quand
je vous demande pourquoi vous avez pas
arbitré en faveur d'un capital français
populaire sur la fusion totale elfes
c'est pas un détail c'est la plus grande
entreprise de France et donc tu mets en
général ça donne l'impression si vous en
souvenez pas que toutes ces que tous ces
sujets qui sont pour le coup de la
souveraineté énergétique française vous
indifférez
ou se fait réagir
non mais je crois monsieur Tanguy que
c'était pas tant une question qu'une
observation
monsieur le monsieur le Premier ministre
je vous remercie très sincèrement pour
le temps que vous avez consacré à notre
commission d'enquête vous avez vu que
la nature des travaux parlementaires
un peu changé correspond peut-être aussi
à l'époque dans laquelle nous sommes
mais nous vous remercions très
sincèrement d'avoir participé à nos
travaux de les avoir préparés et pour
toutes les
réponses que vous avez apporté qui
permettront nécessairement d'éclairer de
contextualiser nos travaux merci
beaucoup monsieur le Premier ministre je
donne rendez-vous au membre de notre
commission demain pour la poursuite de
nos travaux